there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody we are back it's wednesday
it's gonna be a good show tonight yeah
it's a paranormal extravaganza
[ __ ] everybody loves it when we
do the paranormal because you know i'm
probably gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
you might make some [ __ ] out of the bag
yeah i might think
i'll make [ __ ] fall or he never can't
that would be cool i might put wigs on
there's no no
we'll see
don't tease us like we'll see how much
how much the alcohol affects me
i'm drinking vodka tonight
you're drinking my white you don't have
any tequila you don't have tequila oh
one focusing on vodka oh you told me
that you had you had balloons for
tonight you didn't no we're gonna booze
for tonight but it's gonna be vodka oh
okay yeah i mean uh
the price of tequila is going way up way
up
it's only i can only buy it i can really
only afford to buy good [ __ ] if i go to
sam's
yeah and so i guess you got it far yeah
yeah yeah yeah you gotta wait to do a
whole sandwich you gotta do a whole
sam's run that's why i bought it i
bought two of them fifths [ __ ] last
time then you drank them all already
drink them both
well like not all not all at once i
don't want it
that was a couple months ago a couple
months ago we're not that we're not that
drunk i'm gonna go ahead and plug so i'm
gonna go ahead and plug sam's [ __ ]
tequila sam's silver tequila comes in a
nice big fancy [ __ ] decanter and
everything just like it's and and i
can't tell and it's only twenty dollars
for a [ __ ] fifth and i can't tell it
apart from milagro silver it's good real
good
drink that [ __ ] all day yeah yeah
that's all i'm gonna say about it
is it yeah
i'm gonna try to get me to say some more
about it okay no i just i just thought
you probably would
that same bottle if that was coming from
uh milagro would probably twice that
close to 40.
a lot of what you pay for is now well up
to a point like but after a certain
point like a lot of what you pay for is
branding yeah like you know and nice
packaging and stuff like that there's
anything wrong with that i'm just saying
that i was watching a show the other
night um they were talking about wine
okay
used to be
back in the 1800s and even 1900s
most wine was [ __ ] it tasted terrible
only real expensive wine tasted good
because they knew how to you know get
the right breeds of [ __ ] grapes and
the process that they used in the
factory but they said today the
difference between a 10 bottle of wine
and a 100 bottle of wine is like zero
that's what i was gonna say you can get
a really legit bottle of wine for
between 10 and 20 bucks no shame in that
at all yeah like a lot of them are just
really good and i can't tell the
difference not that i've ever drunk any
super expensive ones he said that if you
took that ten dollar bottle of wine and
jumped in the damn tardis or [ __ ] and
went back to [ __ ] doctor whose tardis
went back to the 1800s and gave that to
those people they'd [ __ ] love it
they'd think that was a
super super fine wine they think you
came from heaven yeah and you got that
[ __ ] out of a damn cardboard box at a
damn [ __ ] walmart that's like the box
and they'd be like oh this is the best
[ __ ] ever because that's what
that's kind of what they were shooting
for well see what it's hard to be alive
yeah as shitty as stuff is sometimes
it's like it's it's easy to lose sight
of what the deal was of how much things
have progressed like if you went back in
time like everything sucked back then
yeah even a poor person here in the
united states lives better than a
[ __ ] medieval king or even in a roman
lives better than a roman emperor you
know i'm not saying it's uh it's a party
to be poor because it's not i'm just i'm
just saying because it's all relative
it's related to like the roman emperor
did not have [ __ ] access to air
conditioning they didn't have access to
[ __ ] uh a telephone in your pocket
that could access the world's
information over the internet didn't
have that
[ __ ] there's a lot of [ __ ] you take
for granted like
food that is safe to eat food that isn't
rotten
and that is a relatively recent
innovation yeah
most people hate startlingly startlingly
recent yeah it would come out of the
candidate it'd be rotten and they'd
still eat it
just read concrete whatever close enough
yeah
so there's a lot of stuff that we take
for granted today and you know people
crying it was just called the jungle
like sinclair that's right yeah uh
people read that in school people uh
crying about poverty today they have no
idea the [ __ ] they're talking about well
like i said it's not fun like to be poor
like relative to you know relative to
other people it's like you know and
nobody's having a party like i said
sleeping on a mattress in a [ __ ]
alley that's not fun for anybody right
but i'm just saying that a lot of times
that's a life choice though
uh i don't know about that oh no well
not not if you're mentally ill that's
not that's not well you don't understand
the bomb culture go down there go deal
with them bombs you give them a house
they'll just walk out of it ah nah [ __ ]
this they'll you know what i mean
they'll [ __ ] it up and then they'll say
[ __ ] it and then they'll go live out on
the street sleep they you know they'll
move to a place where the climate's good
it's like a lifestyle
you know they're they're mentally [ __ ]
up too well yeah but um no they they're
they're you know there are some people
that are homeless you get my house and
they'll they'll they can prosper but
most of those guys aren't like that well
the thing about it too is that if you're
poor for a really long time you really
don't have the resources to kind of like
get your [ __ ] together you've never
really had anything like that danny
rowling says uh barbara hershey squirts
that poor girl did a superb acting job
in the film the entity just saying yeah
that was a really actually good film and
it's really weird because i feel like
forever it's one of those ones that even
though the case that it's based on
is like one of the most i guess well
documented yeah and kind of the most out
there sort of like poltergeist cases
like in the annals of paranormal
literature
and even though the film is really good
i mean it's obviously exaggerated some
yeah especially toward the end
but i kind of feel like it's one that
sort of like is not real it's not like
as well known as enfield or some of the
other cases weirdly even though crazy or
[ __ ] happened yeah this was america's
kind of version of enfield it's about
like on that but that on par with that
kind of enfield i think was more
witnesses
more documentation more cops involved
and and news reporters but a lot of
people saw
the entity case a lot of people saw it
yeah a lot of people and they said it
was [ __ ] weird real weird it's rspk
yeah well that's what uh that's what dr
barry taps is yeah and uh honestly if we
do the story i don't know if he's gonna
do it but i was watching another video
like another girls video about
the entity case earlier
and dr barry taff himself had commented
on the video yeah so maybe he's like
watching i don't know i just saw that he
like commented on it because i didn't
have time to like read all of it
but yeah so he's still around and he's
like still commenting on stuff uh let's
see danny rowling says hopefully tom
gets scared by the house castle story
enough to rock the white matthias wig
yeah the right one i need to get me a
mathias wig
four throw down says do they still crush
the grapes with their feet i don't want
foot wine probably not i doubt it yeah i
think they probably do that like for
tourists like oh it's a lark let's go
like crush and then they throw that [ __ ]
out like we don't want your dirty ass
feet in there no
the wine process the wine making process
is now a [ __ ] like exact science they
can take a shitty [ __ ] grape and make
fantastic wine out of it because they
know what chemically is happening in
there to get the flavors that they want
and science yes they science the [ __ ]
out of it and uh another thing is is
that today you have access to breeds of
grapes that didn't exist 100 years ago
grapes that are much better at yielding
wine but now i don't even think it
mattered you could probably make a great
wine that or at least a decent one yeah
or a decent one you would think was
grapes it's probably not grapes at all
maybe pear
or you know
made out of [ __ ] plums you probably
wouldn't you don't really have to use
grapes
no i've had other kind i've had other
kinds of uh wine that were made of other
things yeah like other than grapes in
there and it's perfectly uh crumbly but
they know how to flavor anything to
taste like anything without even using
uh you don't even really need artificial
flavors they're just the chemical
processes that you can do to make
molecules [ __ ] generate the taste you
want i mean they got that [ __ ] down to a
science literally you can make any case
anything yeah
all life is chemistry yeah it's just
chemistry gramther says oh yeah and i
meant to mention this a gator ate a dude
in largo florida yesterday yeah i saw
that on the news i didn't like read the
whole story but yeah yeah they do that
every now and then
it's it's rare for them to eat a whole
dude usually they'll eat a kid or a pet
there was one i saw somebody sent me a
link to it came off of
somebody's instagram or something
um i don't know if it's still there
they're speaking spanish
taking pictures with their phone over
the bridge and there's damn alligator
with the [ __ ] woman and a drowned
woman in its mouth is he's just sitting
up she's in her dress she's been a
middle-aged woman
and the gators just got her in his mouth
he's just resting at the surface like oh
man here's my snack yeah i can't wait
till this rat's up
yeah i know it's terrible but that's all
the gators thinking yeah and he's just
he's like basking in the sun it's gonna
be yummy
and the
the people are like you know
commenting in spanish like oh my god
look at that look at that oh my god it's
[ __ ] horrifying yeah oh my god look
at that and that's horrifying gators
just chilling and that might be don't
worry i do what i want it might be here
that's probably just down south around
mine yeah it might be south florida yeah
south florida i mean you know
it looked like florida
and the spanish made me think florida
probably
it probably would
i mean you know
there's a big gator
at least 10 feet
probably 12 foot this [ __ ] monster
remember that remember that video that
went viral of that big [ __ ] giant one
walking across the golf course in
florida yeah where are they holy [ __ ]
that's like a damn dinosaur well it was
so big at first that everyone thought it
was fake but then they found some other
videos of it like that other people had
taken like from different angles no it
was real it was [ __ ] enormous and
they can walk upright with their bellies
off of the ground [ __ ] suspended over
just walking like a champ
even the even the tail not really
hitting the ground tail will be above
the ground just maybe the tip will hit
every now and then they can
they can just walk walking damn dinosaur
they evolved to a certain point and
they're just like this okay good enough
this is good we're staying here yeah but
you know you always kind of see them up
around the bank they're dragging their
belly but they don't walk like that when
they're going from one pond to a next
yeah because they'll stand up tall
you know
the back of that thing was that high off
the ground
yeah going by they can walk like that
yeah they can run too yeah
they can outrun a human for a short
distance for yeah for sure it isn't yeah
[Music]
danny rowling then says the doris bither
case is kind of similar to the jackie
hernandez san pedro haunting case in my
opinion yeah i always for a long time i
got those two confused um i read about
both of them now i do want to do a show
about the san pedro haunting because i
don't think we have i wrote about it in
my book but i don't think we've done a
show on it yet like i said we did do a
show kind of
about the entity but it was like our
first episode ever like back in summer
of 2016 and i don't even remember what
we said on there because we also talked
about the shining so i'm sure we only
talked about it for like maybe half an
hour so i don't know how much of the
[ __ ] we covered
but
the thing that's great about
the entity case because i'm going to
talk about housekeeping castle first
because that's not quite as complicated
but the thing about the entity case is
that dr barry taff is still alive
and he wrote this big long thing like on
his website saying like exactly what
happened like every time they went to
the house like you know what i mean so
there's like a really good record
of
the phenomena that happened like in his
presence you know what i'm saying
so
that's really good so that's kind of
like a lot of what i use like for the
notes for this
that he uh that he wrote
let's see
slasher friend says speaking of crushing
grapes to make wine one of the most
famous i love lucy episodes is where she
and ethel are crushing grapes oh yeah i
remember that one i think i think that's
like this the one that i remember second
just after the after the chocolate
factory one i think everybody remembers
the chocolate factory one more than
anything
yeah fourth row now says i went to
gatorland in the 80s and some of those
mothers were freaking huge yeah there's
um i went to the alligator farm
uh
last year last summer in saint augustine
which is similar and they have some big
[ __ ] in there too and they also have
some crocodiles yeah and they have one
crocodile in particular who is [ __ ]
he's not as big as the one that they
used to have there that died but
it's pretty [ __ ] big that's the old
one that they had was named gomek
and uh i saw him when he was alive but
he's dead now so they stuffed him so you
can still see him but he's dead but they
have another one now i can't remember
what the new what the new one's name is
but he's not as big as gomek but he's
still pretty big what's funny is he's
getting a [ __ ] you can hand raise him
from pets
and uh you know they'll tolerate you
they had a family down in louisiana live
near the bio
and [ __ ]
they just had a pet alligator he started
out going that big
and over the years he got to be about
you know four five six feet long he was
in the house so they made him like a
little doggy door
and he could go out build the house
yeah and he could go out to the bike
and he got to where
he would
spend all day outside but then when the
sun started to come down he'd come in
yeah he had a mattress and everything
he'd sleep on the mattress
and they'd give him a chicken
yeah in the morning they'd give him a
chicken he'd take the chicken oh thank
you then you go out to the water
he's like i still might eat you anyway
someday no he said
i would i wouldn't trust him the woman
could go up there and pat on him and
roll him over and pet his stomach and
everything it was it was friendly it
grew up with him
it's weird
you would think that a reptile wouldn't
do that but now that
and uh it got big animals like to be fed
and like have belly rubs and mattresses
yeah i think that thing was about eight
feet long at the time that they were
doing the show and that was back in the
80s
that's crazy yeah and i'm pretty sure
they can feel kind of strong you know
it's good when he gets out of here he's
smelling strong yeah so he comes in and
stinks up yeah he stinks he was smelling
strong so it's good when he gets out of
here bigger he got the more you kind of
stink
you know but he
but they liked him
it was their pet he was a nice dude
yeah he knew they had a whole routine
that's interesting yeah a gator
that's funny and it was wild basically
it was going out every day
going out being an alligator and then
coming back coming back to sleep
grantham sandra said how many viewers
were present for show number one i'm not
sure because we didn't live stream then
yeah it was just recorded just recorded
so i don't even remember i should go
back and look like how many views that
first episode has probably not that many
i don't think
the first stream we did man we had a
bunch of views and we made like a 300
bucks on the very first stream yeah i
think one of them i think the first time
we live streamed was our 200th episode
yeah we're at episode 302 now
so yeah that first stream i think we
made about 300.
yeah because everybody well everybody
kept bugging us about it yeah and we're
just like oh finally okay we'll finally
do it it took me a long time to figure
out
uh mango said that was a great first
step well thank you i haven't listened
to it for a long time i'm like scared to
like go back and listen to the old stuff
who has sued that man
yeah
that's the thing it's kind of like uh
and somebody said that the that summer
wind was their first episode and that
was like a really great episode too oh
yeah i was in a good mood [ __ ]
talking about summer win that was all it
was uh that was all recorded when it
yeah yeah i think that was yeah that was
before we did and didn't we do another i
think we did it didn't we do another
summer wind where we had the guy that
was on the summer wind yeah like
restoration
thing and we like interviewed no it
wasn't summer wind yeah it was was it
summer wind because i thought someone
was torn down by them
i don't remember but it was somebody
that was trying to like rebuild it or
something like that they were having
like or somebody that had investigated
it
do you remember that yeah yeah i
remember it but i don't think it was
summer wind
could go back yeah i'm pretty sure it
was summer win because that's how he met
him
in summer when facebook summer when
burned down
burned down a long time ago yeah i know
that i know that but um maybe they were
going to build another one on top of it
that's kind of yeah that's what i was
saying okay
tammy says uh i've been here since jack
the ripper the one that we
i wanna was that the one that we talked
about um cause we did a show about jack
the ripper i think but then we did a
show like a long time ago that was about
two
poisoners who also happened to be jack
the ripper suspects
yeah so
because i think tammy's been here a long
time
so i can't remember but i don't remember
when the jack the ripper episode was it
wasn't that long ago i feel like
okay so um what's the first case we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about some housekeep castle
yeah and i hadn't either until like
several people recommended it to me and
then like when i went searching i was
like oh my god there's like [ __ ] all
over the place about this and a bunch of
the paranormal shows like have been
there and stuff it's actually it's in
the czech republic
now i will say that i was watching one
channel earlier
um it's called geographics it's the same
guy i think his name simon whistler and
he also does one called biographics
which i really like
and he did a show about houska castle
and he happens to live in the czech
republic he doesn't uh speak czech but
he knows people that do
so he's like the thing about the
housekeep castle case is that a lot of
the sources that people are repeating
from are in english
and the czech ones kind of you can you
can
do more of like a deep dive on the
actual history of the place and [ __ ]
like that
if you can speak czech or know somebody
that does
so he actually kind of like went more
into where the stories might have come
from and stuff like that because i feel
like once it kind of got popular as like
a creepy paranormal place then everybody
kept like repeating the english language
stories instead of going back to like
the original sources you know what i'm
saying but i don't know if that's true
or not i'm just saying that's like what
he said so but most of the stuff i saw
like just repeated kind of the same
stories over and over again but that's
all right
tammy says i remember seeing uh shauna
and thinking she was so cool with her
demon baby yeah that's right that might
have been the 100th episode was that the
100th episode i think it was yeah
let's see
so do you want to start talking about so
you've never heard about this case at
all
never heard of it
you might find i find it interesting
it's like it's a haunting demonic
kind of thing okay you know which which
probably you should kind of like i can't
believe we're starting into the actual
topic this early yeah well we should we
got two of them
yeah
so this one well the reason that i
picked two is one because the patreon
poll was a tie and since they were both
paranormal i was like ah what the [ __ ]
we got two of them and i know that
entity is a big subject yeah well in
housekeeping castle is not all that
complicated yeah okay it's like fairly
short right um so we don't have to go
like super super into that because like
i know that you want to go into the
entity thing yeah you don't like a lot
of poltergeist thing danny rowling says
nazis did some occult practices at that
castle and some nazi corpses were buried
there as well i think yeah i had heard
that as well nazis absolutely did uh
occupy it during world war ii i'd be
skeptical though
well they were no they were actually
there they haven't they have record
stuff but yeah i don't know if they were
doing a cold stuff there but they were
they were there i did a whole show we
did a whole show on that and i've been
reading books about that angle for a
long time
and there isn't as much to that stuff as
you would think there's some esoteric
backgrounds
to there was german mysticism involved
in germany long before uh i don't want
the algorithms to get us so i just
called him mustache man and the men of
the bent cross i'm calling them call
them that there's uh
they
they borrowed a lot from german
esotericism and that like they're like
we have
masonic lodges the germans kind of had
that too and they used those motifs
and uh
what you'd call like uh
new age new agey [ __ ] was real big in
europe especially in germany during the
early 1900s and so was science fiction
and uh mustache man and the men of the
red cross and also the communists and
everything were heavily influenced by
science fiction h.g wells anything that
came out of the
fabian socialist type people from
england they were big into that
it was a futurism science fiction
also
um esoteric [ __ ] and talking about the
past and your ancestors and where you
came from
there's really nothing all that special
about
about the uh uh that party
uh other than the [ __ ] that they did
other than that it wasn't
it was mostly fashion
that's mostly
what you're seeing that it looked a
certain way
and it looked a certain way on purpose
it was to make you think it was bigger
and more powerful than it really was
uh but as far as the paranormal stuff no
they didn't take it seriously well like
i said they understood the power of
branding yeah it was branding you know
and those uniforms were creation of hugo
boss
and he was a [ __ ] very good designer
and they knew about branding and
theatrics and
uh how to how to um and another thing is
that that black uniform that the uh that
the ss used and everything was a [ __ ]
boston police department uniform just
black instead of blue and hugo boss
recut that's that's what it is it was
just high fashion futuristic [ __ ]
that looks real german and
then people can pick it up and just run
with it with their imaginations you know
they weren't really about anything they
didn't even really have any rules but i
got into that go back and look at that
other you can go back and look at that
other episode what i call it nazis and
nicole yeah yeah yeah that's an old one
it's an old episode i think that was
even before we had a video component
because i don't know i mean some of you
guys that haven't been here since the
beginning like a lot of our early shows
we didn't even have video it was just
a slideshow it was just like with
pictures and [ __ ] like yeah we weren't
even on camera until like later on well
that was a lot of people did that back
then you know and they didn't have
streaming functions were either not
either they didn't have it or it was
just in in in beta testing during the
time we were doing that
you know the idea of super chat and all
that was [ __ ]
that didn't start until after we had
already started the show
yeah we didn't get into that yeah
we had other shows before this that only
lasted like a couple of weeks or a
couple months because we didn't have it
we didn't know what the marketing
strategy should be when
when people first started to become
youtubers
there were forms of youtube material
that appeared and were [ __ ] hot for
only about two or three months then they
then they disappeared
couldn't make money with that anymore
long gone most of those old videos
pulled down by youtube
some of y'all probably remember
remember some of the weird
like the way the algorithms algorithms
were it had to be less than five minutes
if it was less than five minutes well it
used to almost kind of like tick-tock it
was way well for a long time if you uh
you couldn't make videos more than 10
minutes i remember that that wasn't that
long ago right
and the material that sold and made
money back then was very different than
what makes money today
yeah remember it was like tick-tock yeah
type [ __ ]
and you know
and i mean the thing about it is that
that's why i was always kind of that's
why i don't really worry about like i
know that some people that have channels
like they really worry about oh this
video got this many views and this one
didn't get that many so i'm gonna do
more of this type of content or blah
blah i don't really i kind of keep track
of that a little bit but not really
because i'm just kind of more interested
in
what would i watch uh if it was me like
what kind of [ __ ] do i like what do i
want to talk about you know [ __ ] like
that so
i don't really worry too much about it
but you know and and i told you even
from the beginning when we started the
show
because sometimes you'd be like oh we
should do you know stuff about this or
we should do like current events or
something like that i said i really
don't want to do that because that that
material isn't ever green i said i
wanted to do something that was more
like you could find the video like six
years from now and it would still mostly
be relevant you know what i mean that's
one strategy that is one strategy but
the current event stuff also is
gets gets big traffic
because you have i know it does but one
i don't really want to do it and two
like after that current event has passed
and nobody cares anymore nobody's going
to watch it yeah true that's that's
that's the downside yeah
and it's like you never really know and
i don't really want to like you know i
have a million other things to do and i
don't really want to like maintain the
stress of like oh what's hot today today
right like what do i have to do today
it's like like i i don't i don't have
the patience for that i don't have the
time for that it's just not i would
rather just do like cool [ __ ] that i
like talking about yeah and
that like i said you know you can watch
it years from now and it's still
relevant information mostly he says
we're blurry
we're blurry we're not i don't look i
don't look blurry that's you man that's
your that's your [ __ ]
maybe you are stoned and you just don't
know it maybe somebody slipped you some
pop brownies
[Laughter]
without you knowing
dj says i'm only late because i had to
stop for ice cream i got bananas foster
eww
eww
yeah yeah that's right fourth drawdown
remembers it he goes yeah i remember the
days if i put a thousand mementos in the
gallon of coconut that just happened
yeah i remember that remember that's
there was [ __ ] on youtube that's all
long gone that was yeah it was like it
was fun challenge type stuff yeah it was
fun but all that shit's gone now like
look i just ate a big [ __ ]
tablespoon of cinnamon yeah watch what
happens i'm like no thanks
it's really not that interesting that
[ __ ] made a lot of money though in its
day
oh i know but i'm just saying well they
didn't make any money for me because i
don't give a [ __ ] about that kind of
stuff the the strategy was to make um
10 cents or a dollar
off of a small fraction of a million
million kids under the age of 15 who uh
paid for it with their mom's credit card
that type of deal yeah
yeah and i mean the thing about it is
like i and also i think it would be even
if i did try to like appeal to like a
much younger audience it's like look i'm
old it's like i don't know what the [ __ ]
the kids today are into and i don't
really care what the kids today are into
yeah all i know and care about is what
i'm into and what i want to talk about i
don't know the way this is the way for
us to go anyway that's what i'm saying
yeah it's like nobody's more what we
wanted to do nobody wants my old ass out
there like trying to appeal to blow up
momentos you know mentos
hey fellow kids nobody nobody wants to
see that it's just pitiful so you know
what i mean
and i'm aware that it's pitiful and so i
would never trust a lot of those people
i have more dignity a lot of those
people that are doing that though aren't
even on camera yeah it's they're taking
pictures of their cats or their pets
running through the damn apartment and
now i will make a lot of money i will
watch cat videos yeah they make well i
make cabins i tape pokey something they
get some cat with some disfigurement or
something and they make it the star of a
[ __ ] show and they make a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of money and here's the thing
it looks very organic but behind the
scenes it's like a professional
production agency doing that
people trying to recruit cats
lighting people [ __ ] editors and
stuff you know and well there's a lot of
money some of them do make a lot of
money because if your cat gets famous
like they'll get like deal like just
like athletes they get like deals from
like big pet food companies and stuff
like that like for their photos and
videos and stuff
so you know yeah they're not as dumb as
they look
people doing that
well like i said that's that is one
thing that i actually will fall for
because i love cat videos
i love ca i love watching cats do [ __ ]
you think but [ __ ] i can just like watch
videos of cats just like kind of lay in
there you know what i mean because
they're cute so
there's that
i wish i could i i don't know like i
wish that i
taped pookie more
because she does funny [ __ ] like all the
time but a lot of times she'll do funny
[ __ ] and then i get the camera out and
then she stops doing funny [ __ ] so she
can go hey what's that and likes yeah
and like start headbutting the camera so
she stops what she's doing so you know
yeah they mentioned his surfing
squirrels yeah yeah and all that stupid
stuff yeah i remember that yeah i saw a
cat snowboarding before which is awesome
that's kind of what i mean i like the
adventure cats have you seen that lately
the uh people that
take their cats like hiking and put them
in little harnesses they ride on the
back of motorcycles and [ __ ] like that
some cats are really into that take them
to the beach and they swim around yeah
that's kind of what i meant about like
it was
like stuff you might see off a tick tock
yeah that's what youtube used to be
although a lot of tick-tock chefs like
what the [ __ ] are they doing they're
slapping their legs down at clothes
change just stupid [ __ ]
how is this entertaining i don't know
although like i said saying that just
makes you sound like a grandpa yeah i
guess it does it just it doesn't
it doesn't look entertaining to me well
it's entertaining to somebody obviously
or nobody would do it or nobody can
watch it it's like a bunch of nothing
i mean i'm not entertained by it but i'm
not the demographic although i would say
uh i was i wouldn't have been
entertained by it even if i was that age
i think so yeah so i don't even know if
it's anything to do with age i don't
think so it only has anything to do with
the age because [ __ ] might just have to
be if i was 15 i would have been
laughing at that at 15. it's like what
the [ __ ] is this like you guys are
[ __ ] suck
i put my venom album on be pulling
cranking up venom you guys [ __ ] suck
i'm so edgy yeah i'm an edge lord
i'm putting on slayer
yeah yeah
yeah that's it thank you aaron sorry i'm
late here is some money
thank you that's okay you don't have to
like we haven't even hardly got into the
topic yeah we're trying to get a topic i
get sidetracked well you know that's
that's how that's why the show is like
five hours long sometimes we gotta get
we gotta get to let's get to the castle
let's go to the castle
we're going to the castle we're going to
the castle we're going to the czech
republic i'm going to make another drink
okay
so
all right
so this particular castle as i said i
had never heard about it until i had
like a bunch of people recommended to me
and then i went on like the paranormal
corner of youtube and there's like [ __ ]
tons of videos about this and all the
ghost adventure shows and all the ghost
hunting shows and stuff like that have
done a show from there
so this is about um an hour north of
prague this castle and it's up on top of
this hilltop like kind out in the middle
of nowhere like it's sort of isolated
it's just kind of
woods and [ __ ] like that around there
so the castle was first built
and i'm not from the czech republic
obviously so i'm sure i'm gonna like
butcher every single name that's in here
so please forgive me if you're from that
part of the world i'm trying my best
uh so this was actually built or
commissioned he didn't get out there and
build it obviously because he's king
king ottakar ottokar yeah the second of
bohemia yeah so he had this castle built
sometime between 1253 and 1278 so you
know 13th century uh it's a very it was
a very gothic structure standard at the
time
now oddly
uh
the original
construction
it didn't have there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] about this castle okay
it didn't have any stairs
going from the courtyard to the upper
floors
one of the weirdest things what you
would you know have castles have
defenses like defensive walls and [ __ ]
like that
it had those but the defenses were
facing inward toward the courtyard
rather than outward so it's more like a
present
yeah okay
uh yeah and that's what people said at
the time it's like it's almost as if
they're trying to keep something in
rather than keep something out yeah uh
so the castle doesn't have any
fortifications it doesn't have a water
source like there's no water source
nearby uh one source a couple sources
said it didn't have a kitchen
um and for several years after its
construction had either few or no
occupants like nobody lived in it
uh i also saw some sources that said
that most of the windows are fake that
they're just like these glass panes but
then they have like walls behind them so
you can't like they're not real windows
yeah
it's a prison gotta be
well
we'll get into it yeah we haven't even
started don't try to guess he always
trusts this yes he always tries to guess
before like he knows any information
yeah i don't know why he does that in
movies too like we're watching a movie
it's 10 minutes in and he's always kind
of like hey this person's the murderer
how much you want to bet and i'm just
like dude just watch the movie just
watch the movie i don't know and
sometimes it's a movie i've seen and i'm
like
i don't want to spoil it but that's not
what happens but yeah
so the location of the castle is also
pretty weird
so it's in this kind of remote area uh
just surrounded by forest and mountains
and swamps there's like nothing really
around there
it doesn't have any particular strategic
value from a defensive standpoint uh not
really near any old trading routes uh
even back when it was built which again
kind of odd
so a lot of people are kind of wondering
why the [ __ ] was this built way the [ __ ]
out here and built all weird like that
so
the folklore the stories say
that what it actually was
was that the true purpose of this castle
was there was this big
story goes there was this big
fissure
in the limestone
the locals believed that this big crack
in the rock
was
a gateway to hell
and the stories say
even back then that it's like
[ __ ] like spirits and demons and [ __ ]
used to fly out of it
and kill people
and like drag them back into the hole
so the story started going that this
castle was built over it like to contain
them like and keep the demons from
coming out of the crack in the earth
okay coming down to the crack of the
earth
the ass
[Laughter]
me too this is like it's like kind of
like the premise of the movie gargoyles
it is now that you mention it i wonder
if that's where they got the idea
although i kind of feel like housekeep
castle i don't think it was widely known
this the story about it until the 90s
like the late 90s i feel like that was
kind of when
at first and then obviously like when
the internet when all the paranormal
stuff started happening but i feel like
so i don't know
i don't know if unless somebody like
spoke check back then and knew some [ __ ]
about like the legends or whatnot
i don't know if anybody like when they
made gargoyles would have known about
that you know what i'm saying
i don't know it was a made-for-tv move
you guys haven't seen it it's back in
the 70s that's the truth we reviewed it
didn't we yeah yeah i'm pretty sure
i think it's free on tubey as well
so it looks like maybe like a
well-meaning king decides oh man this is
the crack out of the earth where the
[ __ ] demons come out of
i'm gonna have to build a [ __ ] castle
here to guard this [ __ ] to protect the
earth he's doing something just back all
that [ __ ] spackle it over that's right
yeah
you don't gotta build a whole castle
ever i mean that doesn't seem like oh
yeah yeah because i should have had
jenny with you you should have jenny
with you you could come up with that
instead of building you can just pour
some concrete in there that'll be out of
the castle take those bricks and just
stuff that crack up
yeah problem solved yeah see even tom
wouldn't have thought of that
that's why i'm the brains of the
operation that's right
yeah nobody said like i said that seems
like a lot we'll we'll build a whole
castle over well how long does that
[ __ ] take yeah
build a flat slab over that [ __ ]
we'll see but that's there yeah they did
that too but the weird thing okay will
they do that too well yeah build a flat
slab over there like i said this is how
the story goes out of the story the
castle is there i'm not saying the lick
is made up but yeah
so apparently that's why the castle was
initially built at least according to
local folklore because it's trying to
cover up this pit uh from which the
demons emerged
now again story goes that the chapel
of the castle which was actually built a
little bit later i think because at
first see i think the king first built
it as like an administrative
which is hilarious to me which is just
kind of like well i have this other
castle or this other thing over here but
we don't have room for all of our
paperwork so let's build another castle
like over there like to put all that
[ __ ] in so i don't think it was made for
anybody to live in necessarily i think
they just had like a couple people like
watching it it was really cool um yeah
did you like [ __ ] like that
but
eventually like enough people lived in
it that they needed to build a chapel
because of course you need a chapel
so when they built the chapel
they
at least according to the story built it
right over the bottomless pit because
they thought you know the religion will
like keep it all down in there yeah
jesus seal in the evil like it's like
[ __ ] demonic tupperware is that what
it is
so
it wouldn't be demonic tupperware it's
heavenly tougher
heavenly temperament
well it's demonic tupperware in the
sense that it's keeping the demons in
there
it's keeping them right it's keeping
them fresh yeah yeah yeah
demons yeah demonic tupperware
oh my god that's going to be my next
like marketing angle i'm going to like
[ __ ] keep the demons fresh
demonic tupperware parties i can imagine
like a whole thing
but yeah so
people still go there today and they
claim that they can hear
uh kind of creatures like scratching
from under the floor and trying to claw
their way out [ __ ] like that and heard
like screams and whatnot
now here's one of the
like best known stories about this place
so apparently um maybe like a couple
centuries after it was built
they were kind of like look we got this
like pit in the earth we think there's
demons down there that are like coming
out like with big [ __ ] wings and
stuff
so we'd like to know
what the [ __ ] is going on down there
right
so what they do
is they have all these convicts
and they say to the convicts
okay you guys um
we will give you a full pardon and
they're like really wow and they're like
okay but wait we're not done
to get a full pardon you have to do just
one teeny little teeny little favor and
they're just like what is it what is it
we'll do it
okay we're gonna put you on a rope
and we're gonna lower you down this hole
which supposedly goes to hell and we
want you to come back up and tell us
what you see down there
and
most of them were like nope i'm not
gonna do it but a couple of them
according to the story did do it
so uh so yeah so they thought this hole
was bottomless i don't know but like i
said they didn't know what was going on
there but uh you know locally they
thought that like demons and [ __ ] were
flying out of it
so the story goes that the first guy
that said he was gonna do it was a young
guy in good shape everything like that
so he's like yeah cool pardon i'm i'm
all about it
so they put him on the rope and they
lower him down into the hole
couple seconds go by
and the dude starts
screaming down there in the darkness
like pull me back up pull me back up and
he was freaking out
so they pull him back up
and
according to the legend
he looked like he had aged 30 years some
of the stories also said that his hair
had turned completely white while he was
down in the pit
uh they said he was still screaming when
they brought him up to the surface
and he basically uh flipped out and they
had to send him to an insane asylum and
he apparently died two days later from
unknown causes okay let's back up for a
second let's back up first
let me get this straight
they lowered a guy down i didn't hear
all of it but i'm gonna i'm gonna
surmise they're gonna lower a dude down
in the basket to see where it goes well
he was a convict and they said they
would give him a full pardon if he
agreed to like be lower down this hole
and tell him what the [ __ ] was that okay
how far down
well i don't know it's bottomless
it's like i said it's a story how long
was the rope did i say no okay so he
comes out he's aged and crazy yeah that
sounds like it's very similar to the
story about the dude that had the hole
in his backyard went to hell on our belt
yeah and put the who
i kind of feel like hole to hell is a
pretty common like story troop yeah
you know what i'm saying you know what
i just remembered something what's that
this was f this was featured in search
of oh was it because i think it might
have been i think i remember a
reenactment of them [ __ ] lowering a
dude down into the pit when he comes out
he's crazy he's hearing ah they're
putting in like a bucket
yeah they put him in a bucket or
something he's in his big bucket and
they put him down there and he comes
like ah yeah it becomes a hit
so here's the leonard namoy talking
about it you know making it sound more
making it sound like it really happened
jim
[Laughter]
he's so logical everybody
well here's the big question
if somebody came to you okay now
cast yourself back if you lived in this
area and the story was everybody
believed that there was this crack in
the earth and like demons flew out of it
and [ __ ] and like snatched people and
like dragged him back to hell and went
saying crack and snatches and [ __ ]
flying out of cracks and snatches that's
just getting tom's getting all
distracted
okay sorry sorry about my word choice
okay but
um and say you were a convict and you
were either you're gonna have to like
break rocks for like 20 years or
whatever and they said all you got to do
is be lowered down this hole
and we'll let you go would you do it
yeah i would too you should [ __ ] right i
would
i was thinking about that isn't that
stupid i was like thinking about that
earlier like when i was reading through
my notes and i was like if they'd asked
me to if i would do that i'd be like oh
yeah i totally would i would even
hesitate yeah i'd probably pretty much
do anything probably
like don't break as long as the rope
doesn't break and you don't drop me down
there i break my back or some [ __ ] like
there was a certain this whole going to
prison thing you know i mean i can
understand that i guess that's better
than like being beheaded or just
hanged for for minor offenses and stuff
kind of like europe used to do
but there ought to be like i kind of
liked other [ __ ] like trial by combat
trial by ordeal that's another thing
that's pretty cool too all right
like um
let's say you know you're guilty okay
and they're they're gonna [ __ ] give
you 20 years all right but they give you
an option you can do trial buyer or a
deal if you pick up this [ __ ] 10
pound red hot [ __ ] bar of steel
and pick it up with your bare hands and
run with it across the [ __ ] you know
floor run with it like [ __ ] 30 or 40
feet and put it inside the bucket then
you're innocent i'm gonna take that
[ __ ] trial bar a deal
you know what i mean
they just run with ah [ __ ] they did it
kane did take kane did that [ __ ] and
kung fu
where he picked up that remember we
picked up the red hot [ __ ] brazer and
left the [ __ ] dragon scars in his
[ __ ] forearms and [ __ ] hell yeah so
i'm gonna hurt for a second that's what
i'm saying it's like i would i would
much rather take something that was just
gonna hurt for a little while right
rather than something that was like 20
years long you're right so being in
prison for 20 years oh he was innocent
you know
you know yeah
it's just saying right
i mean i but i'm a lunatic too you know
i mean i [ __ ]
i'm a reasonable lunatic though you know
i have reasons for being you know with
the way i am i'm thinking i also believe
that they should bring back dueling
there is
no reason why legal dueling is is it is
not constitutional
if the state has the right to
[ __ ] draft people
and send them to wage war against other
people it's not even your fight that's
if that's legal
then it should be legal for one citizen
to [ __ ] wage war on another as long
as they both agreed to it
get out of me and it and that was never
adjudicated they just kind of said yeah
we're not going to do that anymore
there's like a generational thing
they need to bring that back up into
congress that should be constitutional
yeah i don't think that's going to come
up for any anytime soon oh my [ __ ]
beer
you just need to have the right lawyers
make the argument
that it was never adjudicated
because think of it think of what you
could do you could monetize that you
could stream that life you could sell
concessions or anything you know tom
versus the you know the whole thing yes
right i'm gonna get you [ __ ] you
know and they have all the same rules
and everything they're choosing weapons
and the location and it's all televised
like something out of them
who's that [ __ ] movie with the
nightingale [ __ ] the girl with the
damn
hunger games
like hunger games except it's you know
you're agreeing to it it's private
warfare
okay let's get back to this
i want to talk about it well you've
already started you've already discussed
that at great that was another show i
don't know
another show
uh john gore says around 10 years ago i
tried to see the entity at anthology
film archives in new york city but each
time i showed up i got the day in screen
time screwed up i slept there twice at
the same time it's a good movie
it is it's it's decent it's it's weird
because i like i said i feel like it's
not as remembered
as maybe some of the other ones but it's
actually it wasn't totally worth
watching it wasn't as high budget as say
like poltergeist well yeah spielberg yes
it was about like on on par with like
dead zone and
fire starter probably better than fire
starter i think it was better than the
starter about like dead zone
this is pretty good
yeah i'm really liking it now like i
said i was scared at the time i was a
kid i mean the end goes a little bit
okay but you know hollywood and yeah and
up until that point it was exaggerated
but pretty close to what was actually
reported but the end of it was like
pretty much a complete fabrication
so
so yeah so the guy okay so the guy gets
lower down in the hole and story goes
that he came up and his hair was all
white and he was crazy and then he died
two years two two days later actually
rather in an insane asylum
so now in 1541 this uh bohemian
chronicler named vaclav hajik i'm not
sure i'm pronouncing that right
he wrote
this thing called the czech chronicle
and he said
that
actually this particular area where
housekeeping castle was built
was kind of like well known for being
this sort of woo kind of place you know
what i mean where maybe that hold the
hell has been there a long time i don't
really know but he said there was
actually a little fourth there in the
9th century
and
that prior to that there had been uh
stories about this crack in the cliff
that apparently like all these demons
and like half human hybrid type
creatures would crawl out of and like
eat the livestock and [ __ ] like that now
as i mentioned earlier about stuffing
the thing full of concrete or whatever
apparently
back then they did try to like put rocks
in there at first but like the rocks
would just get like sucked in
so i don't know like why if you just
tried to fill it then that didn't work
but then if you built a castle over it
that was like hold on one second what
pat hellfield pat hetfield i think
identified what it was i remembered it
wasn't an in search of he said it was an
old rod sterling pilot
he says i think called encounter with
the unknown oh i remember that worry
about a pit someone goes down there to
find out what's going on comes up the
screams and runs out in the woods that
was it
i think that was that's right i saw that
it was from uh he said rod sterling said
it must have been the night gallery
right
no it wasn't night gallery it was a
night gallery no okay it's a different
show it's called encounter to get known
it's on to be i think all right i
watched it a couple years ago okay yeah
i saw i saw that but i remembered it as
possibly uh
in search of well the thing about it
though i mean we'll get into maybe why
the story is familiar
in a little bit
um um what uh john smith says he didn't
think that dueling was legal it was just
something that they did no it was legal
at least in the united states it was
you had to have a lawyer to do it they
showed up to it and you [ __ ] signed
documents and it was all it was all
legalized
it was probably like that in europe too
uh okay so as i said uh the king
apparently had this gateway to hell
sealed with stone plates like i said and
then built the chapel on top of it
um at least according to the story it
had kind of like all the chapel was
dedicated to
uh the archangel michael
so there's that
now 1639
again so the story goes
the castle was
occupied by a swedish fella a mercenary
named oronto
now this guy was allegedly into a whole
bunch of into like a cult [ __ ] like
black magic and whatever
and he apparently was trying to find
some kind of like immortality elixir or
something and that he was like working
on that in this castle
and apparently the villagers around
there were so scared of him that
two of the two of the guys that lived
around there like said we're gonna go
shoot this [ __ ] and like went and
assassinated him um but so that didn't
really help about this like aries
reputation
it should be noted though that this
chronicle that was written in 1541
no one's entirely sure how much of it is
actually true and how much of it is just
like local folklore
because they're not sure if this aronto
guy like this swedish fellow that
supposedly practiced black magic in
there like if he ever really existed
like i said it's hard to say because it
was a long time ago but they can't
really find many other records of him
now the castle did actually kind of
trade hands between a bunch of like
nobles and you know families and stuff
like that
um it was renovated in the 1580s
uh had kind of started to fall apart you
know around the 1700s 1823 it got
restored
now in
1923 uh a guy named joseph uh shimanek
shimanek who was the president of skoda
auto
purchased the castle uh to live in
now
okay so here's another story about it
1836
apparently this guy who was a czech poet
and his name was carol maca
and he spent the night there
and he said that he had all these
horrible like visions and dreams while
he was in the castle
and he wrote this letter to his friend
edward hindell which still survives in
which he described these visions that he
had
he said that he had dreamed about his
soul descending into the pit and then
going into
the future
prague 2006 and he said everything was
mechanized and it was horrible and he
hated it and he was just like wandering
around in despair
um
yeah so he also saw like i don't know he
saw a bunch of things that sort of
suggested like what the area looks like
now you know what i mean like so it's
almost like he saw into the future or
something like that so he has supposedly
wrote this letter in 1836
now in the 1940s uh when the nazis took
over
this particular area
they took over the castle
no one's entirely sure
why they took it over
like i said it was 30 miles from prague
it didn't really have
that many like it didn't have any
defenses it wasn't really strategically
important or anything like that
one of the leading theories was that
himmler needed it for his library
because you know he had like that
library of like you know jewish
mysticism and all his esoteric books and
stuff like that and they thought that he
was maybe using it as a temporary
library like to keep a lot of his stuff
there yeah um okay and some people
thought that well no i'm just saying
that some people thought well they know
where some of the books are yeah um and
they think that they were there at some
point because they got sold off like
later on so he might have been keeping
the books there
like this big occult library that he had
and some people like i said thought that
they wanted to occupy this place in
particular just because of the legends
like surrounding it whether they whether
they believe them or not i don't really
know you know i i didn't say that they
actually did believe them i'm just
saying they maybe liked the so yeah
sometimes they did things for
psychological reasons pr and stuff they
you know [ __ ]
their uh
psyops departments would kind of like
get old [ __ ] nostradamus
nostradamus quatrains and prophecies and
kind of re-calibrate them to make it
look like they were talking about how
they were winning the war and stuff so
they were big into psyops
getting their hands on castles and stuff
that would be kind of like their style
most of the most of the most important
castle that they had that was vevelsberg
which is where they it was like the
uh where the training cadre and the the
the military academy where they made uh
shoot stuff or ss that's where they made
them which there were a lot of different
kinds of ss but that was like their main
academy and it did kind of have a kind
of a spooky look to it in parts of it
but then you looked at the other parts
of it it was
pretty modern
most of that [ __ ] bent cross [ __ ]
was kind of pulled out of the ass there
wasn't a lot to it they were trying to
make it more than what it was because it
didn't have a history
you know
it was begging for a history though they
were trying to give it its own mythology
and
trying to tie it back everybody likes to
make things like more spooky and
mysterious right it was actually just
kind of
hokey really but because of what
happened
towards the end with the holocaust it
kind of
that right there made it seem like uh
like more serious than it really was
when most of those dudes didn't even
know about that but that right there
made it
made that whole thing real sinister
had the holocaust not happened you had
forgotten about those guys you didn't
even take them seriously
yeah i mean probably
because it would just come off kind of
hokey
you know
yeah like some cheesy acids yeah black
metal right exactly
[Laughter]
that was just the ss and stuff you know
uh they just had the army and everything
else most of the stuff that you know the
the branding was just
traditional german really you know they
hijacked all those looks and all those
fonts and and all that stuff from stuff
that was around before
and then
had the holocaust not happen that stuff
would have been kind of just forgotten
but because that holocaust happened it
kind of
colors all that other stuff as if it was
some big
sinister juggernaut you know
professional scientists and [ __ ] you
know
i guess you say like villains and
cartoon villains and that's not really
what it was it was really just
made up as they were going amateurish
well that's kind of true of everything
yeah i mean things only seem to have
a pattern or significance or something
like that in hindsight in hindsight
because you can see the results the
results right you know when it's
happening it doesn't seem as significant
because you don't you can't like cast
your mind into the future to see how
it's going to turn out yeah you know
what i mean which maybe is our curse but
maybe a blessing also yeah most of the
stuff that they're famous for that you
brings into your mind was a product not
a [ __ ] hitler the asset it was a
product of joseph goebbels and he was a
real good advertising agent he was the
minister of propaganda and he branded
them he made them look the way they
looked he selected all that stuff from
german history to put that together into
this just super german patriotic looking
thing and that's what you're remembering
it but it's an it was an artificial
construct they didn't invent any of that
stuff they just remixed it it was like
the greatest hits album
that's really cool they just cherry
picked [ __ ] they like and like put it
all together into like kind of like a
narrative exactly
exactly and it was a copy of communism
that's all it was they they looked at
the communist party they saw that hammer
and sickle and they go damn that's
awesome we gotta have something like
that and they came up with that damn
swastika and they didn't invent that
they borrowed it
they got that from eastern's philosophy
it's just a yin yang sign that's really
all it is
yeah like the four winds yeah you know
the axis on which the earth turns yeah
that's that that's it's the pole and
it's sad because for a long time like in
eastern religions they you still see
those right it's like it doesn't have
anything to do with this but now it's
tainted because of that but it didn't
used to mean that nothing really special
or original about them it was just a
german communism that's all it was the
only difference between
russian communism and german communism
is that russian communism was focused on
class
german communism was focused on race
because they said race is class
which if you're looking at these
scriptures basically that they're
reading it's marx you know you could
interpret them in a lot of different
ways where yeah i guess race is a class
that's all it was
and uh they didn't get elected to do all
that
all that [ __ ] holocaust [ __ ] that was
just the end result of them collapsing
and trying to take down all their
enemies with them because they knew that
their time was was over
so they were going to get rid of all
their ant political enemies and and they
called them racial enemies they were
going to get rid of them all because
they were going to die and they did
all the dudes that actually believed in
that [ __ ] went down with a ship they're
all dead
old mustache man said the germans failed
they weren't good enough for us
you know and then you had ss units
running around [ __ ] killing german
civilians that were surrendering to the
allies and stuff kill them as traitors
so you know
they were a [ __ ] extremist version of
a [ __ ] con of a german communist that
was
big into racial identity politics that's
why these people that are talk all this
[ __ ] in this country dangerous because
that leads down a very dangerous path
don't define people by race people are
individuals they're not racist
they're just not
when you start looking at that way then
everything looks like a race war and
that's what happened with to the damn
germans they interpreted everything as
some form of a race war or an attack
against them and their race and other
races attacking them and trying to
replace them and this and that
don't look at life through the lens of
race
you're going to miss out on a lot of
good people
well i don't think anybody here needs to
hear that
that's just my advice does a lot of
people do that startup 78 said did you
two ever cover the coral castle we
haven't
i don't think we didn't do a whole show
about it but i think we did talk about
it like on one show because i remember
bringing it up but i don't think we did
a whole show about it maybe i should
look back and see
because i do remember
you know what i think maybe we talked
about it remember like sometimes when we
used to do like little news things like
at the beginning like i might have
talked about it like uh briefly at the
beginning of like another episode
but i'd have to look back and see but
yeah i did want to because i we've just
seen it in search of about it you know
what i mean
john goris says i love the old pulpy
men's adventure magazines from the 50s
and 60s with the mid-century germans
doing weird stuff with hot babes torture
baboons robots voodoo etc those are
great aren't they yeah i mean yeah they
had some crazy [ __ ]
uh so yeah
uh where was i okay so
yeah so we don't know i mean i'm sure
the nazis wanted this place one because
it was there and it was in territory
that they'd occupied castle two it was a
castle that had some kind of like creepy
occult [ __ ] about it like legends about
it going back hundreds of years they
probably thought that was neat um like i
said they do know
pretty much
you know with some certainty that
himmler kept a lot of his uh occult
library there they do know that
but whether they actually did
experiments there
like
you know trying to
crack into the hold hell or whatever i
don't know if that's true or not but
that's kind of like the stories but
there's also kind of the thing where
they think that it might have been one
of the outposts that they use
um like the ss had the like the breeding
farms like where the
the
pure women were going there to like talk
about the babies yeah yeah yeah well
they they were like having the babies
for the body for the fatherland so i
mean that's not crazy either because
they did have other
buildings where they had that and it was
like remote so they're like yeah maybe
they're not totally sure though let me
uh mention something before we get off
the subject of uh the [ __ ] bed cross
and himmler and [ __ ]
that's another figure that his [ __ ]
kind of in hindsight becomes something
that he's not
if you understand the high command of
the damn germans they were like the mean
girls club all they did was [ __ ] with
each other and [ __ ]
and just [ __ ] bag on each other and
most of it had to do with what your
military
history was like in world war one that
was the pecking order among the generals
at the bottom what basically was hitler
himmler was like the [ __ ] he was a
chicken farmer he was kind of [ __ ]
scrawny [ __ ] he was considered
to just be like a
a nerd a super super nerd
and they just made fun of that guy and
he really wasn't given a a whole lot of
responsibility he was in charge of these
ss guys
but it was more of a figurehead than
anything else and that's all he did is
he run around he had the anna derby
going out trying to find
the source of the aryan bloodlines and
[ __ ] and it was all just pr and
propaganda they got hitler on tape
making fun of it you know what i mean
they just thought it was funny
uh it was just [ __ ] that they would
twist for pr
to give them more of a history and a
more of a
credibility and to try to make them
have a legend to him
but himmler was a dork he was you know
at a personal level he was he was the
kind of guy that you if
you'd bag on him if you knew him you
know um
and they did kind of make fun of him the
the the senior
generals and and the senior party
officials just thought he was a joke
but uh
that's this everything has to do with
your point of view you know among his
peer group he was he was the dork
[Laughter]
he didn't do much and then he took his
own he seems like a dork he's just a
dork yeah and he was more of a paper
pusher than anything else and he was the
kind of guy that would be like obsessed
with d and d
like old school yeah that's how he
always struck that's what he was that's
exactly right nothing wrong with d i'm
just saying yeah he just seems like one
of those there were guys jewish guys
that
worked in concentration camps
and
kind of
saved their own lives by being valets
and [ __ ] to some of these guys running
the camps all right
and they said that there was a marked
difference between these dudes when they
had that uniform on or off
when they had the uniform on it was like
they were
they're like they were larping they were
[ __ ] powerful and sinister they'd go
out and [ __ ] murder people personally
by [ __ ] shooting them in the head
with pistols and stuff real vicious but
then in their private quarters where
they'd be running around in their
underwear they were just [ __ ] dorks
well that's metallization yeah they were
totally compartmentalized
that happens a lot like people that had
you know you put on a uniform you put on
a costume you put on something yes like
you act totally different
i mean that's a pretty uh that's a
pretty well studied like cycle yeah and
you know this one valet was like and
when they those uniforms were cut
specifically to make them look
intimidating and muscular and [ __ ]
broad shoulders but when they
but when they weren't in those uniforms
they were just narrow shoulder
pot bellies skinny fat
nobodies really and they were kind of
selected for that in certain you know i
mean those dudes running those camps
where they were all gonna die they were
all gonna get rid of those guys
they were gonna erase that those things
had ever existed
and guys like himmler and these guys
they were just
tools
by a political party
to
to
kind of promote an image that was
false that's not how they were really
thank you zack the entity is one of my
favorite horror movies the director did
that great michael caine movie the
ipress file yeah that's right and it has
similar imagery with all those weird
abstract camera angles yeah i really do
like the entity uh a lot startup 78 says
uh he also did superman for the quest
for peace lol
we're not going to hold that against him
the entity really liked that movie
though man go ahead i like that movie
the entity really is a genuinely scary
unnerving movie it is dj maniac says i'm
sorry everyone i think i'm just gonna go
to bed exhausted and depressed as of
late oh i'm sorry it's all right but you
go go get some rest yeah go get some uh
now superman [ __ ] uh superman four
actually was uh
one of the better ones i think that was
better than three
and uh that was canon's best movie
it's kind of a low bar though a little
bar but that was
i kind of think we saw it and i i
enjoyed it it was [ __ ]
it's bad it's stupid stupid [ __ ]
crazy but i had fun with it but it's
still energy it's funny yeah
uh danny rowling says the entity is a
far superior film uh to this 1978
amityville film
yeah probably say so i think it probably
is yeah i mean in in retrospect yeah i
think i would have thought the
amityville horror was better a long time
ago but now that i've seen them both
more recently
yeah i kind of do think the entity is a
better movie although i do think the end
i wish they had stuck with
they had done a different ending on the
entity because
it just
you know it's just strained my
credibility a little too much like i
couldn't really go there with them but
you know
um okay so where was i yeah so
after world war ii was over
the family that had owned the castle
before
they took back over like they got
ownership back and that same family
apparently still owns it uh to this day
now they opened the castle to the public
in 1999 like as a tourist destination
and in this area it's pretty much the
tourist destination it's pretty much
like the only thing to do around there
um so the thing about it is that
i don't know so okay so people go there
today like i said all the ghost hunting
shows have been there
and one of the weirdest things about it
and i've seen photos of them hey poke
she's on the show he's on the show hey
what you doing baby girl
she was like hey she really didn't want
she's looking at the cat wall no she's
she wants a meat stick you want oh you
want those tuna sticks don't you why
don't you go get her one okay i'll get
her one in a bit i mean i need a drink
too anyway
yeah she uh those tuna meat sticks man
she loves those things oh my god she
doesn't like the salmon though
well and the thing about it is that if
you go to the grocery store like the
publix has salmon ones and chicken ones
but no tuna ones for summer the tuna
ones are really hard to get hold of for
some reason
so it's kind of like so i went there the
other day and i was like well [ __ ] all
they have is chicken and salmon and i
know that tuna is her favorite so i got
chicken and salmon and the chicken ones
she'll eat the salmon ones she kind of
sniffs and she's like looks at us like
these aren't the ones i like and well
i'm like i know but that's all we have
and she's like do i have to eat it i'm
like yeah you have to eat it and then
she'll eat it but she's like not happy
about it so i had to start ordering the
tuna ones
off amazon like for 16 bucks you get
like a big
box like with a [ __ ] ton of them and i
just put it on
like a subscription so it comes like
every two or three weeks because she
eats the [ __ ] out of those every time
like you're in the as soon as we like
settle into the bedroom at night like to
watch movies or whatever she comes like
trundling in and she's just kind of like
she sits there by the end of the bed
like stares
like with her eyes real big like next to
the drawer like where the meat sticks
are she's just like sits there staring
staring staring like she's trying to
like
tell a [ __ ] with her mind
they're like you want a beat stick
and actually if you don't know where she
is you just take the packet out and rip
it and she just comes running like
wherever she is she's like means take
time she's so excited and she has like
this whole routine where you have to
hold it you have to hold it like that
and then
she has to like lick it for like a long
she won't bite it at first she'll just
like sit there and lick it with her eyes
closed like oh yeah that's some good
[ __ ] right there and then like she'll go
chomp chomp chomp and like she'll eat it
but then you can't hold it anymore
because she'll bite you and then you put
it down on the ground and then she gets
mad because you ruined it then she just
she storms out of the room like
you [ __ ] it up and then she you so she
leaves like this little bit on the floor
and then she comes back in later and
we're like you can't have a new one
until you eat the old stuff and she's
like i don't want to eat that when it's
all dried up now we're like well whose
fault is that so it's like an argument
every single day
and she knows she knows how it goes
eventually if you like argue with her
enough she'll be like fine and she'll
eat the pieces and she's like now can i
have a new one now you can have a new
one she knows the rules she's a good
girl it's just like really funny
um let's see strong78 says the entity is
so
scary because all the possibilities it
teases in the beginning actual ghost
actual intruder insanity or her son are
terrifying yeah i mean this is a pretty
[ __ ] up and honestly i'm not like the
biggest believer in the paranormal
obviously but
this story is like pretty weird and it's
like pretty [ __ ] messed up
uh zach says i don't blame her those
jerky meat steak type things are one of
my favorite snacks just wish they were
less greasy
yeah and the two i don't know like like
i said the chicken ones she likes the
salmon ones she's not into even though
she's really into the tuna ones and the
tuna ones are so stinky you guys but i
don't know why they don't sell the tuna
ones in the store like you have to order
them
so i either get them from amazon or
chewy but they don't have them in the
store she's calling for it she's like oh
my god yeah
she hears the paper yeah she hears the
paper she knows that i was telling them
about the whole i was telling him about
the whole tuna meat stick routine that
she has
like how we have a whole thing about how
she leaves the the little dregs on the
floor we make her eat the old ones
before we'll give her a new one yeah and
then she doesn't want to do it and she's
real relieved
i don't want to eat it and we're just
like no you have to do i have to and i'm
like yeah you have to
and then she will and then we're like
okay good girl she gets into this thing
where she just licks them yeah
you get an eater you're gonna yeah and
she goes she goes into like this like
what like oh yeah like it's kind of
she's just like look at it and you have
to hold it if you drop it she gets upset
she gets mad
and she like shakes her head and runs
away
stamps her
she has a very specific way that she
likes to do things she's a human child
and if you don't do it right she gets
very very upset about it like i said
she's the same way with the with mommy's
hairbrush yeah she's the same way with
all that you have to do it exactly right
or she gets like really upset and starts
like yelling yeah
she looked she was another thing that's
funny about this cat i've never seen a
cat that has facial
expressions
i looked over and she was slammed next
to me in bed and i looked over and she
looked at me like this you would
i was like her face was like
[ __ ] you
want why do you have facial expressions
she does have like you're a kitty cat
you don't have patience she does though
yeah
you can totally tell you can tell when
she's mad you can tell when she's like
she well she makes like mad faces like a
human she's like her little her little
eyes go like that like like a person's
eyebrows would like she could she's like
like if she's mad mad faces and what the
[ __ ] you looking at faces yeah she's
like she looked at me like she went
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
right
okay we gotta get back
all right so
so yeah
so after this place
um
got
famous like i said it was kind of well
known in world war ii obviously because
of the nazi thing but then it sort of
like fell into obscurity for a little
while but then
i believe in the 1990s
like a magazine article came out that
was talking about it that was talking
about the history of it and like all the
legends about it like yeah it was built
over crack to hell and all this other
kind of stuff
and that article
was picked up i don't know if the
article itself was translated into
english or if somebody that spoke czech
and could also speak english like um
sort of popularized the story and from
then it was like off to the races like
all of the paranormal channels picked it
up and it became like really really
popular so like i said all the ghost
hunting shows went there and everything
so i feel like it wasn't really until
the late 90s when
the story kind of like became really
like widespread so a lot of people go
there now like they do actually get a
lot of tourists and stuff so in the
chapel though there's pictures of it
and these paintings
that are in there
are pretty weird they're not like so
weird that you're like what the [ __ ]
alien race invented this but
they're weird in the sense that it's not
normally the kind of paintings you would
see necessarily on
um chapel walls from this time period
they're a little bit pagan
but i mean that's not necessarily weird
because i do kind of feel like some
christian stuff in the middle ages still
had like a pagani flavor to them but
there are some weird images on they're
very very violent and like really bloody
like there's like bears tearing people
apart and [ __ ] like that there's that
um
one of the paintings on the wall
has this kind of creature
which has it's kind of like a centaur
um but the top half is a woman and then
the bottom half is a horse like a
centaur but it's a female female santa
are you um
now
so the
a lot of people have made much of the
fact that the centaur
is shooting an arrow with its left hand
which you know left-hand path that
satanism all that other kind of stuff
and especially in the middle ages it
kind of was as well so some people have
speculated that maybe there's something
to that
um and those paintings are authentic
they are from the middle ages they're
not like later extrapolations because
like i said the place was kind of like
redone in the um 1800s but you know
now so people that go there nowadays
um many people have reported uh screams
coming from beneath the floor scratching
noises i think that's probably the most
common thing um sounds like something's
trying to like you know scratch through
the floor a lot of people report that
um
people say they have like kind of bad
luck after they leave like really bad
[ __ ] happens to them um that they don't
even want to go in the building like it
has like really really bad energy or
whatever some people have spent uh the
night there and seen like various like
uh
apparitions shadows and stuff i kind of
feel like there's like a woman that
peeks out the window like people see
that as well they also have like a bunch
of sort of paranormal groups like meat
there like ufo groups and stuff like
that they kind of have conferences there
as well
some people claim that the place was
built according to sacred geometry
and that it may be a portal for time
travel which you know okay
um so yeah so travel channels done
legendary locations uh they did a show
there they did ghost hunters
international that was in 2009 they went
there most haunted live they were there
in 2010. now as i mentioned earlier
though
a lot of the stories about this are kind
of like hard to verify because
so many of the so much of the sources
that people are
repeating
are english language sources and rather
than the original check sources so this
one video that i saw which is the
channel is called geographics he also
does one called biographics which is
also really good
but as i said i believe the guy that
presents it like lives in the czech he's
british i think but he lives in the
czech republic
and so he used a lot of like um czech
sources
and he said that a lot of the stories
about this are actually kind of dubious
um
he said that the first stories about the
spirits coming out of the ground like
near the place like there did seem to be
kind of like weird legends about the
area
but
they didn't the stories about the
spirits coming out of the ground didn't
really like
become widespread until a couple of
centuries like after the castle had been
built in the 13th century
and it doesn't really talk about a big
crack in the earth that the castle or
chapel was built over
they just kind of described it as like a
hole or like a crack in the earth or
like the rocks or something and the
chapel wasn't even wasn't built over it
it was just kind of like on the grounds
type of thing
also it's possible that the letter
that that maca guy like wrote to his
friend saying they had the vision about
the demons like dragging him into hell
and stuff they are not sure but they
think that letter that guy did exist
apparently but they don't know if that
letter was a forgery or not
uh so there could be that
and the story about being lowered down
into the hole and going crazy and like
you know your hair turning white and all
that
that may have come from a short story by
a guy named ernst wenzel
and the story was published in 1870. now
it wasn't like about that castle i don't
think but there was an aspect of that
story where somebody like a convict or
something got lowered down into a hole
and then like he came back up and he was
all crazy and [ __ ] like that
now it is possible that the author of
this story from 1870 was using some
folklore that was already around
um or it's possible that this is where
the stories of that came from from this
particular short story because we've
seen that happen before where
a short story
uh that people kind of like forgot about
they just like remembered the details
but they didn't remember that it was a
fictional story and then like later on
it kind of like takes on a life of its
own and then people like think that it's
true so i kind of feel like
because didn't we do a show one time
where it's like there's no legend says
this and that and then they found out
they traced it back to like some short
story somewhere and like everybody just
remembered that so i think that does
happen sometimes because you know you
read a lot of [ __ ] over your life and
sometimes
i mean i've read stories before and i
was like wasn't there a thing where blah
blah and then like i figure out oh later
on it was like some short story i read
when i was kid yeah
they got me that way when i was a kid
and i think they got most of society
when i was a kid
they told us that the first uh pers
first westerners who ever reached china
was marco polo he explained explored it
and everything
turned out marco polo was a work of
fiction
that that never happened
the oldest [ __ ] copies of anything
about marco polo
is over in italy i think is one that
where the oldest copies were it's
obviously a fictional account
he's going there and talking to people
that have dog heads
he's becoming a ruler over parts of
china
it just there's all kinds of weird [ __ ]
in that original story and he does not
describe china
properly it's a work of fiction it's
basically star wars
of the [ __ ]
of that era they didn't know what china
was like they knew it existed somebody
wrote a fictional account of it
some you know oh yeah marco polo went
there and he there was no the chinese
have no record of anybody named marco
polo coming
to meet them and it
it was during a period evidently where
there was a bunch of wars going on and
no that didn't happen there was no marco
polo
but people take that as historical
but the thing about well the problem is
and i don't think people are doing it on
purpose it's just that they got handed
down over and over yeah once it gets
handed down over and over again and
enough people have repeated it and the
original source is lost yeah then it's
very easy to think oh well obviously
this happened because all these other
people said that happens they're quoting
they're quoting memories and what people
remembered in certain books and that but
um i looked into it just a couple years
back
italian scholar says no we have the
oldest copy of it it is obviously a work
of fiction
yeah
yeah well you know
i think we talked about that too like
remember that show we did on like um
40 in archaeology where you were talking
about like the the uh
frogs inside of the rocks and like the
the bat creature like that was the
stalactite or whatever yeah and
at least one of those was an actual
fictional fictional story that had been
published in a newspaper right that over
time people had forgotten that it was
fiction originally published as fiction
people just remembered the details and
like reported it back right and you know
and if enough people do that then you
can go back and oh there's sources that
say this is true
but
you know this shit's wrong written down
in the 1400s man you know i you got
people in the 1700s thinking it actually
happened sure you know and like i said
it's nobody's fault it's just that's
just kind of like
[ __ ] happens right i mean there's a lot
of information produced even before the
internet and it's like jesus christ back
then people wrote letters people wrote
books people wrote like there's just
tons and tons of information out there
and it's really really hard
centuries later to determine like where
exactly that original there was a time
and where there was a time in british
and even american history
where king arthur and the knights of the
round table was semi-historical
that's how it was taught to you as if
that actually happened it didn't it
didn't happen did we do ever do a show
about king arthur no i'll be a good one
i wrote it down like on my on my thing
because i was like oh i don't think we
ever did a show on that that actually
might be really interesting yeah pure
pure fiction french
you know it's french fiction
and the thing about it too is that a lot
of times a fiction writers i mean i've
done this most fiction writers have done
this and back then they did it too
sometimes they base it on some [ __ ] that
really happened you know what i'm saying
edgar allan poe for example a short
story that he wrote was based on a real
murder he changed like a lot of the
details
but the thing about it is that like if
enough years go by
then the two things will become
conflated you know what i mean so either
people think oh it's completely
fictional or oh it's completely true
even though it's muddled up by
fiction that's what happens we have
british subscribers they can chime in in
the comments section but i think
the whole king arthur thing was taught
as british history up into the 60s i
think so maybe even 70s
they could probably they could answer
that but i remember as a kid
when they told us about that i think in
middle school
i think i think if i remember correctly
it was
it was considered to be
semi-historical
but it can't be well the thing about it
like when you say semi-historical i'm
like you know it's it's entirely
possible that it was based on a real
person at some point
but because
it's been through so many iterations at
this point it's just kind of like it
might as well be completely fiction
because it's not really about that
person anymore
i'm not saying the original story wasn't
loosely based on a real person it might
have been uh it might have been i used
to kind of think that but it's kind of
like the whole jesus well that's what
i'm yeah well that's what i mean it's
just kind of like well [ __ ] the era that
they're talking about must have been
[ __ ] towards the end of the roman era
which is like 300 a.d and [ __ ] there
wasn't one ruler there was a bunch of
[ __ ] warring tribes
you know what i mean
and there wouldn't it couldn't have been
a [ __ ] they definitely weren't
wearing the armor they're depicted too
depicted because that's french armor
from the [ __ ]
late renaissance period and stuff you
know but uh
they were talking about the late roman
period for brit
you know or right after the romans left
which i think was 300 i think
startup 78 said speaking of duels have
you all seen ridley scott's the last
duel
using using a judiciary duel to settle a
rape accusation you know what it's like
we saw the trailers for that and it
looked really good but then like we
never got around to seeing it which one
was that the last duel remember we saw
trailers for it it's ridley scott it's
recent it was only like a year or two
the one with adam adam um driver it was
adam driver in it yeah he might have
been oh no the guy who played
a guy who's in star wars
um
he played um
what's his name darth sidious or
whatever his name is
uh what the one with the knights right
does everybody talk about
yeah
it's called the last duel yeah that they
heard it was good
it just it well it tanked at the box
office but that doesn't mean that it's
not any good though i mean it looked
good from the trailers yeah what's that
guy's name he was the guy that played
[ __ ] kylo ren adam driver adam driver
you already said it okay i wasn't sure
if that was his name yeah okay he was
the same guy that was in yeah don't die
and so it's the same one i had that
recommended to me a [ __ ] story that
had that recommended to me when that
came out that that was really good
it looks good from the trailers and we
were gonna go see it but then it seemed
like it was only playing for a week or
two because nobody went to see it
and then
[ __ ] vanished movies were [ __ ]
dead
so i mean you know everybody's saying go
see [ __ ] uh the new top gun everybody
[ __ ] loves it
they say it's badass
real entertaining
real jets flying and stuff we have to go
see that [ __ ] sometime this week yeah
i want to see that i knew well i want to
see the new a24 movie
all right um blair dude says the gospel
of mark is a parable mistake in his
history
and the other gospels are a doctrinal
war yeah pretty much there's nothing in
the new testament or old testament is
historical not really i mean other than
yeah
other than i mean yeah they use like a
couple sort of like historical things in
there like to color it up but mostly
it's just it may as well be greek
mythology fiction that's what it is it's
uh
it's canaanite mythology and hebrew
mythology which was the same thing in
the old testament and then kind of a
greco-roman
judeo
mythology
in the new testament there's nothing
historical they're including the
crucifixion
that the dates are wrong
the characters are wrong the way the
crucifixion was taking place that's not
a roman execution it looks too much like
the [ __ ]
jewish uh ritual scapegoat escape goat
ritual
which is the
being you know where you slaughter a
lamb and the tribe's
sins are washed away with its blood and
then [ __ ] the evil goat is left it's
it is let go and but but you know this
uh which is barabbas
and uh so it's the scapegoat ritual
that's all it is
that's what the crucifixion is that's
why
it's the blood of a demigod it's so
powerful it can wash away all of
mankind's sins no matter where they are
all throughout time in the peasant
present past and future
only it's not a normal lamb it's a
demigod it's half human and half god son
of god like hercules this is all the
same
european religious tropes over and over
again they're just rebooted in the old
testament the new testament actually
isn't written that well there were other
ones that were written a lot better
other religious it's kind of a hillbilly
version of a [ __ ] religion i mean i
kind of i find all that [ __ ] fascinating
i fight i find all that [ __ ] fasting
well the same story troops turn up over
and over again which like i said it's
not crazy because humans are we're all
the same
you know what i mean like our brains
kind of work the same way so it's not
surprising that the same [ __ ] would
under the same circumstances would like
turn up in in our stories european
religions were all a big business and it
was a scene and they were competing for
for followers it was big business in
rome
and you had to use tropes that people
knew there's a lot of dionysus in there
there's a lot of [ __ ] greek mythology
in there
um it's
you had jews move that left
uh [ __ ] uh judea and moving into the
roman empire and blending in with romans
so they're romanizing judaism
and it's a hybrid religion it wasn't
just christianity
the persians came in they did the same
thing with uh
oh [ __ ] what was it name
mithras
you know
there was another religion called
mithraism
that was a big competitor with
christianity and it was the same thing
but persian persian and roman
and uh a lot of that mithraism and
mithraic [ __ ] motifs got blended in
with the new testament all that last
supper and 12 disciples and and
everything before resurrection that's
mithras
so it's all the same tropes over and
over again it's the greatest hits album
of the romans that's all it is
hugo says the last duel is a great flick
a friend of mine did the prosthetics for
the movie okay let me check it out yeah
and it's really or somebody sent it to
us you love ridley scott yeah
it might be available to stream right
now i'm sure it's been a good if it's
really this guy here that's good i'd buy
it
yeah for a couple dollars more you get
it on [ __ ] discs see i like the hard
copies like i said it looked good like
from the trailer it's just we never got
around to seeing it because it didn't
play for that long here yeah northbound
was great and we saw it i want to get
that on on blu-ray too danny rowling
says the 1991 made for tv film the
haunted on the infamous smirl haunting
is a pretty underrated good made for tv
film starring jeffrey damon aka dale
from the walking dead and sally kirkland
also on youtube i think i saw that yeah
i remember that being really really good
like a couple other people recommended
that as well yeah see blairo knows he's
talking about earlier christians did not
believe that jesus was an actual living
person that he was a celestial being he
was one of god's sons one of the angels
in heaven
and you if you appealed to him he could
get you around god's judgments just
through grace yeah there's a lot of
stuff that they're they're playing games
they're squirreling the text
as as the tech
they're squirreling the text as [ __ ]
scientologists would put it but no it's
it all makes sense if you lived in the
in that world
you're talking about the mcu in dc and
star wars these are mythic tales of a
culture and they're fanboying the [ __ ]
out of it all right it's not religious
stuffy religion as you know
it's not that stuffy [ __ ] of the 21st
and the 20th century they were cooler
back then it was the mcu of the day well
it's the same [ __ ] that goes on nowadays
it's just that nowadays are people a
little more sophisticated and they like
know that that's not and back then they
might have not known that it wasn't
right i knew they knew i think that it
was just like stories yeah i think they
knew it was stores i mean they're
stories that convey uh you know a moral
or a lesson or something like that
that's all and in temples going to a
temple back then was like going to a
club they had music they had special
effects and statues that moved they
drank and they took weird drugs and they
paid to go they paid a cover charge to
get in
and it was an event
you know so it was like going to a club
you got your money's worth in religion
back in the ancient days
you know [ __ ] some of it was about
drinking breast milk
imagine that that's that sounds like a
damn fetish club well i'm pretty sure
that [ __ ] does happen well there's a
whole sub
culture of fetish of fetish of they were
into the bubology
biology buddhism and they're all into
like spraying the birds yeah spraying
the milk
yeah yeah so it was that's all religion
could be whatever you were
in the mood for well it's like it's not
like they had anything better to do back
then really i mean that was kind of like
their main entertainment they didn't
have tv or nothing right so it was i
invited today's standards and modern
standards i would call it
badass nightclubs is what they were they
were nightclubs
but it might be happening during the day
but they were definitely taking drugs
some of them they were having sex there
was temple prostitution going on dancing
stage shows
narratives being told and stories yeah
it was a competition you had to have the
best [ __ ] right so everybody would come
to your [ __ ] right and they're going to
sell your salvation through it
so it had to be good back then
you know and they didn't have the
uptight uptight
moralities that you had today they
didn't see it the same way it but it is
we would call it a club
that's what we would call it
just they had a religious aspect to it
but
clubs have religious aspects if you're
in a good club scene
they're cult-like
yeah yeah
we're goths we know i mean it's a little
different nowadays because there's a lot
more like entertainment options but yeah
i mean the thing about any any
subculture that's based largely around
night clubs and i'm talking particularly
about the goth scene like the you know
the gay scene stuff like that um which
is kind of built around i mean a lot of
it
you know that's kind of like your place
that's the place where you go it's like
you meet other people that are have the
same interests as you and it's just kind
of like
it's like and it's almost like a refuge
from the regular world too yeah and goth
people are bringing their kids to it
yeah like you know
[ __ ] um jen who's a friend of ours
his
wife the dj brought her daughter and
it's so [ __ ] funny because we had her
over the house last time we started
she's a little kid she's 12. she was 12.
she's 18 now and she looks like a 25
year old woman
yeah we just saw her
she brought her to memento with her
boyfriend her and jen
walked out i was up at the front talking
to the bouncer her and jen walked out
the crowd of guys looked at him both and
were like damn
because
it's a mother-daughter team but they
look like they're [ __ ] five years
apart yeah they really don't look like
they don't forget
they're and they're both i mean jen is
what she's really good-looking she's
younger than me but not by much couple
years she's she's only a couple years
older yeah she's only a couple of years
younger than maybe four years maybe
something like that and and um
everybody there knows that that's mother
and daughter and that
there's a big age difference between the
two but you looking at them you just
wouldn't know it
no not at all it looks it looks more
like oh
older sister younger sister type thing
and they're both really good looking
really good looking like models and
dudes are like [ __ ]
and these are goth dudes going [ __ ]
because that's like
that's not possible you know but
it is
it does happen it happens yeah it does
happen
well the thing about that is well that
was funny i was talking about and i was
talking to jen uh earlier you were in
the bathroom or outside talking or
something so i was talking to her for a
long time at the club
last sunday
and um
she was saying like i said we we had
seen her daughter
she had brought her daughter to the
house a long time ago like she was she
was 12 right yeah she was 12.
and we gave she was into goth then and
we gave her like a bunch of boots and a
bunch of like a bunch of boots that
didn't really fit me or anymore and i
gave her some clothes and stuff like
that she was like oh my god that's so
awesome and stuff but then like she went
through her an awkward teenage phase
where she was like uh that shit's like i
hate that [ __ ] and she's like she's she
wanted to look all and but then when she
got older she got like way back into it
and now she's all into like joy division
and [ __ ] like that too and i told jen i
was like i told you she'd come around
it's like she was just like trying to
rebel and get her own identity i get
that like teenagers do that but i said i
know that she's gonna like come around
at some point that's what we're talking
about that's jen that's the mom
yeah
she's got a she's got a couple daughters
that are because she has another
daughter they both look just like that
well she has another daughter by her
first husband who is in her early
twenties
yeah she's not she's not into goth
though i think she's more like well she
does come to the club sometimes but
she's more like quote unquote normal
looking
but the the younger daughter who's 18
has like you know here she's like
a pierce nose and [ __ ] like that yeah i
don't know if she's black hair she's all
about [ __ ]
yeah i mean that would be kind of weird
to like to show that but yeah maybe it
would
well she's uh she's 18 though
yeah i know but i'm just saying okay
yeah it is like it is pretty funny it is
pretty funny
not everybody brings yeah
damn but a lot of no i wasn't lying dude
if i'm telling you i'm telling you
something is true yeah
they look like models she's a vocalist
for a band called uh 13th angel 13th
angel yeah
i've done a couple of their album covers
yeah
uh thank you zach rebelling from a
subculture based around rebellion i
think she broke the matrix
yeah well the thing about it it must be
really weird i mean your parents yeah
yeah and it's like anything your parents
do is just kind of like by definition
dorky like you don't want to do the same
[ __ ] your parents do like up to a
certain age like when i was younger you
know i was kind of because my dad was
like real into the beatles and stuff
like that and i was like whoa i'm into
that too but then like for a while in my
teenage years i'm like i don't like want
to do the same [ __ ] my parents are doing
that's weird
but
you know then you kind of like once you
get a little bit older like you
appreciate it but
it must be really strange
i didn't really have the experience of
like growing up with goth parents so i
can't imagine what that must be like but
it happens i mean it happens a lot like
i said a lot of people that we know that
are our age have kids that are grown and
they come to the club and come to the
club and have grown up with that their
whole entire lives so i can see how
i can see how she kind of like rebelled
against it like she probably thought it
was super cool like at first she's like
oh like my parents like wear all these
like [ __ ] weird-ass clothes and like
listen to this weird ass music and go to
nightclubs all the time and she probably
thought it was like super cool well her
dad's her dad's uh
he's like one of the top djs in orlando
so yeah and her mom's in this bed and
they just go to events
yeah yeah so
that's your parents so it can't be cool
and then she goes out there goes no i
guess that is
[Laughter]
yeah for a few years in there she was
just kind of like i'm gonna go listen to
hip-hop and i'm gonna do this that and
the other thing and jen was just kind of
like whatever and i said you know what
she'll come back around yeah she came
right back and she did
it took a couple years but she came back
around i said i told you i told you she
was like i guess you guys are cool i'm
like yeah see
so now she's hanging out with the old
folks
not everybody there's old yeah but we'll
be yeah there's young people in there
we'll be gone and they'll take over yeah
that's the thing a lot of people there
are like younger people so
make another drink here john gore says
we're variations of our parents
kind of kind of
although
i mean it depends on who your parents
are i kind of the weird thing about it
is that i have some similarities with my
parents but
a lot of my
personality a lot of my interests and
stuff like that i'm not entirely sure
where that came from
because i don't because my parents
aren't really into like that kind of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
i'm just i it's almost kind of like i
came out like my my parents aren't
really into like
spooky [ __ ] they're not under horror
they're not in anything like that
um they're not anything dark at all
they're not really anything i mean my
dad was into music but
you know he was real into like 60s music
he liked like a lot of you know he liked
the beatles you like the doors you like
then i like that too but
it just seemed like
i didn't really know where like a lot of
my proclivities came from and they
didn't know they were cool about it i'm
not saying that like my parents are
actually really cool they had me when i
was when they were really young they
were only like 18 so they were like only
out of high school
um
and they were just kind of like yeah we
didn't know we were doing but i was like
you did okay like chill out but um you
know
but there was there was that but i don't
really get
they didn't really understand i think
like because even for a pretty young age
i'm like i like spooky [ __ ] like i like
witches and ghosts and i wanted to wear
like weird black [ __ ] and i like that i
liked all this music stuff and i think
they and i wanted to watch horror movies
and they didn't really get it but they
didn't really like stop me though they
were just kind of like well that's just
the way she is so i guess that's just
what we're that's what she likes so
that's just what we're gonna do so
they'd you know buy me little scary
books and take me to the video store and
let me like rent horror movies and stuff
like that they were very cool about it
but i don't think they
understood it because they were totally
not into that so i'm not really entirely
sure where that came from
i'm not really sure
i can't really think of anybody else
in my family it's basically just like me
and my siblings because i have three
siblings i don't know if you guys know
but i have um i have two brothers and a
sister they're all younger
and all of us
are kind of into creepy [ __ ] like to
differing degrees i think i'm the one
that's most into
horror and goth and stuff like that but
you know my sister is real into she was
real into like some gotham like
rockabilly and punk and stuff like that
my brother was in a punk band you know
so we were all kind of like into that
darker [ __ ] and i think like my parents
were just kind of like
i don't know whatever
whatever we don't know how it turned out
but okay so i don't really know where it
came from i don't know it just kind of
like came out of nowhere uh rebecca said
my mom was into horror movies big time
and supernatural erotic see that's
awesome
i think i would have i mean i don't
really like i don't want to say that
i don't want to say this necessarily
because you know because my mom is
awesome but she is totally like not into
the same stuff as me she does not get
the horror thing she does not like it
um
so she's not one of those people's like
oh nobody should watch it it's just like
nah it's not for me she just doesn't
really like it so i can't imagine what
it would have been like to grow up with
parents that are into because sometimes
i see
like i'll watch like some horror
channels on youtube and some of them
have kids and like their kids are like
all into horror as well and i'm like man
that's so cool and i was like what would
that what would that have been like if
you had like grown up in a household
that was just like hey let's watch the
evil dead like you know with your mom
and dad it's like how cool would that
have been but
yeah i didn't have that i was just like
watch it by myself or like with my
friends because my parents were not into
that kind of [ __ ] okay we probably need
to get back to the subject
okay well we're pretty much done with
housing
so we're going to talk about like the
doris bither case okay yeah all right
been waiting for this bundy says
supernatural erotica oh my god don't you
even know that's like that's
you know what that's not even a subgenre
that's a genre genre that is massive
supernatural erotica
i kind of feel like that's one of the
biggest
like sort of things of erotica is
supernatural [ __ ] and like people that
you know like women having sex with like
werewolves and stuff oh my god it's a
massive massive massive
it makes so much money you don't even
know we're saying we should do a dna
test
we should be
we should do a dna test
do a show about the our dna test is this
never what you think
i don't know
i did um
i did dna through my mom's side
of the family like remember like a long
time ago like national geographic was
doing a thing where they were trying to
study like the migrations of like
populations like
since we came out of africa or whatever
so um so i did that but they could only
because i'm a woman they could only do
my maternal line if i wanted to know my
paternal line i'd have to have one of my
brothers do it or my dad and they
haven't as far as i know
but
all i know is that
my mom's side of the family going back
a really long time
was basically from around
turkey
that's where they came from and then
like went up into europe like later on
and then came over here
so there's that
um
strawdog 78 says my mom was a movie in
horror or not but her only option was
whatever's on tv late at night i
remember watching stuff with her when
she thought i was asleep oh that's nice
yeah i don't really i have no idea
seriously i have no idea where where my
love of creepy [ __ ] came from because it
absolutely did not come from my parents
[Laughter]
even though it feels like it's genetic
but i'm pretty sure it's not because it
didn't come from them
all right so let's talk about the doris
bither haunting aka the entity haunting
now interestingly every single other
thing that i've seen about this case
calls her doris bither but dr barry taff
who was one of the investigators on her
case calls her bither
okay so i'm not really sure i mean he
knew her so presumably that's how you
write about
it's just weird because it looks like
bither but who am i to say i don't know
but i'm just i thought that was really
weird because i was watching an
interview with him earlier and i was
like he kept saying bite her and i
thought that was like interesting
so most of these notes that i'm taking
came directly from the horse's mouth
this is right from
dr barry taff
he was the guy that investigated this he
was there over a period of 10 weeks not
like 10 weeks solid but he was there
like several times over a 10-week period
and this is stuff that him and all of
his guys like saw
around this particular case now i will
say that prior to him showing up there
doris did have a story that as soon as
she moved into this house in culver city
california
so one of the first things that happened
was like this random ass woman
knocked on her door
and said this house is evil
and like you need to get out of here
and like she didn't really take it all
that seriously at the time she thought
it was like kind of weird but she was
like okay whatever just in coffee but
[ __ ] yeah it's in california that's
where the house was but like i said that
can't be verified because that was just
something that she said happened so i
don't really know
so as i said the notes that i'm taking
are coming pretty much from from barry
taft this is [ __ ] that he saw
um
firsthand and this is what he was
writing about now the account that he
wrote that i'm going from i think he
wrote this in about 1999
or somewhere around there and he might
have um
you know updated it like more recently
because he's still around i think
so back in 1974 when this happened
dr barry taff was working in the
uh parapsychology lab
which was then run by a woman named
thelma moss now she started out as an
actress
but she became a psychologist and a
parapsychologist later and she's kind of
like um one of her big things is uh
remember curly and photography yeah and
like aura type of stuff
yeah she's like
yeah she's like real into that kind of
stuff so she was like running the
parapsychology lab uh at i think it's at
ucla that dr barry taff was working on
at the time
so
um as we might have mentioned before uh
this particular case uh inspired the
1978 novel
the entity which was written by frank
defilitta who was the same guy that
wrote uh audrey rose uh you know by the
way
and uh this was made into a film in 1982
which is very good audrey rose
movie odd movie not reincarnating
reincarnation yeah it tried to be like
exorcist but
it's hard to do that with with
reincarnation it's not scary
yeah it's a i mean yeah reincarnation is
generally not yeah
it's not an inherently scary concept but
if you want to see it it's weird but
it's not like scary do you want to see a
weird um
exorcist knockoff see see emily rose
weird audrey rose audrey rose
yeah
it is a weird it is very weird um
anthony hopkins is in it yeah like a
very very young anthony yeah it's a
well-made movie it's just not as scary
as
as is
i mean as long as you don't go into it
like thinking that it's going to be
scary it's kind of eerie yeah but it's
not scary scary back in the days it
probably would have been maybe a little
eerie i remember it being like creepy
when i was a kid yeah because i saw it
when i was a kid
what's it called just audrey rose that's
audrey rose yeah okay
yeah
and like i said that was based on so
frank defolita wrote
that book as well as writing the entity
that was the movie that was based on so
he wrote like a bunch of stuff like that
that was based on like real stories and
frank defilitta the author was actually
at
some of the sessions
that we're going to be talking about
like all of the stuff that happened with
doris bether like he was real interested
in it and he actually got to be friends
with doris like over the course of the
investigation so that's kind of what
inspired him to write the book i guess
so this whole thing started
um well the investigation started august
22nd 1974 and like i said it was
happened over 10 weeks not solid but
they went back like a whole bunch of
times like over this 10-week period it
was in culver city california
so what ended up happening
how they ended up meeting her
meeting doris just like they show in the
movie
now
dr barry taff and his associate
carrie gainer
were in a bookstore
and they were kind of i guess they were
like in the occult book section and they
were talking about like a case they were
working on or something like that
and apparently doris overheard them
talking
um
and she
said he even said it was hunter's
bookstore in westwood village in
california
so doris ever heard him talking about
like like paranormal stuff
so she comes up to carrie gainer
and says um oh by the way my house is
haunted
so harry kind of like asked her about it
and he's like okay well you know give me
like your number and i'll contact you
about and we'll like talk about it later
you know what i mean
so they did end up i mean because it was
in the area
so
burying uh barry and carrie i didn't
even realize until there's now that
their name is rhymed but barry and kerry
decide well the house isn't that far
away we'll drop by and see what the [ __ ]
is going on
so they go to her house now
barry said okay
the house that she lived in i mean she
was a single mom she had four kids
and the house uh reportedly had been
condemned by the city twice
and barry even said in the interview
it's like technically she really
shouldn't have been living in there
because it wasn't really livable he's
like it was kind of
just really not in very good condition
and it's tiny the house is still there i
think um i mean there it is staked a
high heaven smell like garbage in there
yeah he said it was just
he didn't say a [ __ ] hole but i mean you
could tell that's what he was thinking
he said it was like a [ __ ] i see
i've seen uh interviews with him he said
it just smelled like [ __ ] rotten
garbage in there which is terrible yeah
was she a hoarder
no okay i think she was just i mean just
she had four kids okay uh three of which
were boys and three of which were like
teenagers so they were probably making a
mess of things and she probably didn't
have a lot of she had like you know
she worked a lot so i think she didn't
really have time to like
keep everything clean and like i said
the house wasn't in real good shape okay
i think the house is still standing it
is very small yeah probably worth two
million dollars in l.a
i'd be curious so somebody look on
zillow and see
i saw [ __ ] like what uh danzig's
[ __ ] dilapidated [ __ ] long beach
looking [ __ ]
1950s [ __ ] nothing house and that
[ __ ] sold for like 1.2 million dollars
what
that dump [ __ ]
now i'm kind of curious like how much
this has because like i said i've seen
pictures it looks like somebody has
you know kind of fixed it up a little
bit this house but it's still like tiny
yeah and
you know
i'd be interested like how much it had
to see how much it costs
but yeah
so so yeah so they go to her house
now
they go there
and she says okay
so doris at the time was uh about 30
years old
uh in like mid mid to late 30s he said
she had four kids as i mentioned she had
a six-year-old daughter and three sons
one of whom was 10 one of whom was 13
and one of them was 16.
um so they actually like talked to her
and they talked to all the sons they
said we didn't see the daughter we don't
know where she was
now one of the first things that all the
kids said when they interviewed them on
this first visit and like i said this
was just random they met her in a
bookstore she said hey my house is
haunted and they
were in the neighborhood so they're like
[ __ ] it we'll just drop by and see what
the hell is going on
all the kids said yeah there's like um
this apparition that they see in here
and they call it mr who's it
and they said that it would um
appear in quote-unquote semi-solid form
they said it was over six feet tall
and
doris and her oldest son who was uh 16
said that they'd seen
two dark solid figures with asian
features
you know like ghosts of asian people
um kind of like materialize in the mom's
bedroom
and they seem to be like fighting with
one another
they said that this occurred several
times
and in one case doris said that she had
physically bumped into the apparition in
the hallway oh excuse me ghost
asian ghost
yes there's been chinese in the area i
guess i don't really know
um
so
so there was that so that was kind of
the story
now
doris told the investigators
that these what she called asian beings
yes those asian beings that's a little
problematic that's funny that's what she
said though they're just asian beings
they're asian beings yeah uh we're evil
and uh
that basically she thought that her
whole entire family was in danger
so at this point the investigators are
like uh okay
what else you got
now then
doris drops a bombshell on him
she says oh by the way
three
uh quasi-invisible like as in
semi-visible beings
have sexually assaulted me in this house
two of them are littler and they're the
ones that hold her down and then the big
ones will rape her
the big one will ring here
now she said that this had happened on
multiple occasions she couldn't see him
um yeah they were kind of invisible like
i guess like she said semi-visible so i
guess she means maybe they were like
kind of like shady
or shadowing kind of i guess
so she said that that happened and she's
like yeah she's like look i have bruises
all over and cuts and stuff like that
she has bruises on her ankles and wrists
and her boobs and you know in her inner
thighs and stuff like that
i guess i mean you know if she is really
being raped by a ghost that's like not
funny but yeah
zach says according to redfin the house
is 1143
square feet which actually isn't that
small that was bigger than a house i
under daytona and worth uh yeah 1.28
million yeah that's california price
yeah three beds one bath here it would
be a tenth of that probably a hundred
twenty thousand two hundred thousand i
mean a house that size
that would yeah that would be even three
bed i mean one bathroom
one bathroom um a lot of people aren't
gonna buy a house that only has one
bathroom no
this huge ass house that i bought two
stories
all these bedrooms [ __ ] three
bathrooms
it was only 475 000.
yeah this is a five bedroom three bath
yes it is that's right yeah no three no
it's three and a half three and a half
yeah because there's one down but
there's a half bath down by the laundry
i just never know yeah and um it's three
and a half yeah and this house is
relatively new like 12 years and this is
what 4 500 square feet 4 500 square feet
yeah i think
yeah something like that it's pretty
cool house it's not very pretty on the
outside but i'm gonna fix it
doing landscaping and stuff
eventually yeah eventually
kind of basic looking it's a big yard
it's kind of basic [ __ ] looking on the
outside it is very square square like a
square it's very square
yeah adriana said what's the standard
cost of a house in florida it depends on
what city i mean around here like now
prices have gone way up uh in the last
couple years people are [ __ ] flooding
in here
but
like we said this house
it's
just like everywhere if you're closer to
like a big like a city like closer to
orlando it's going to be more yeah this
house which is about 4 500 square feet
it's five bedroom it's three and a half
bath
this was what four four 75 75
um
[Music]
to buy yeah uh but it's a little bit
rural
it's on the very edge of the city yeah
which that's good that's where you want
to be right now it's like rural right
outside of like suburbia so it's like
suburbia but then like right there's
still farms here and everything
yeah like if you drive out that it's
just like all farms actually across from
our neighborhood is a big farm yeah
cattle farms cattle ranches and horse
farms and stuff
so you know but you know
30 miles we're downtown
yeah with the with the freeways the way
it's set up so it's just
mostly you know so you can yeah you can
get down to downtown orlando like it's
35 minutes like half an hour yeah yeah
from here yeah
so it's it's not bad yeah there's
traffic here's nothing like la you know
i grew up [ __ ] long beach you know
left in 81. you know my a lot half my
family's still there
it just doesn't compare
the only the only thing that was ever
like this and ever ever in california
would have been kind of like vista
around vista maybe or oceanside
california back in the 70s
very early 80s was kind of like this
which is a good thing
yeah
um
this has to be 4 million in in
probably 3 million
4 million
in california it probably would be yeah
i mean because it's yeah large this big
it's large it's big and it doesn't cost
that much to cool it that's the thing
that and i got two well it's not that
old it's not i mean they built stuff
that was more energy i was amazed i got
two central systems out there and they
don't even hardly work that hard and i
can keep it a 70. i mean our electric
bill is like less than it was less than
it was at the other point it was half
the size and the old place was like half
the size yeah it's a lot less it was
only one story yeah
well like more glass though a lot more
that's true that house is made out of
glass
i mean it had like a lot of big windows
yeah it got like a lot of sunlight so it
was harder for it to
cool down
this one's kind of like what this has a
lot of windows but
i don't know for some reason it doesn't
seem that hard to keep this house cool
and plus like like you said it has two
air conditioning units
so yeah so she claims
that these three entities
are holding like two of them are holding
her down and one of them is raping her
so she has all these bruises and stuff
like that
now she said too and this happened
before the investigators arrived so they
couldn't verify it but she they said
this is what she told us
it said during one particular time that
this happened
like her oldest son i think his name was
brian or no maybe that was the youngest
one i can't remember what the oldest
son's name was he overheard what was
going on and he comes into the bedroom
and
he says
that he saw her
like so it looked like something
invisible was like throwing her around
like she was just like a rag doll right
so he tried to like help her
at which point he says some invisible
force like picked him up and threw him
backwards into the wall
so
yeah so he said that he had he
corroborated some of it
now
as you would like these
parapsychologists
they were kind of like as soon as she
told that story
they were kind of like okay
this lady is
nuts and probably needs like some mental
help because this is crazy
now
she hadn't reported anything
to you know she hadn't gone to like a
hospital to have like her injuries you
know uh
and you know to have her injuries looked
at
so
this had happened like a few weeks prior
to the investigators getting there
so
they couldn't really substantiate it
and so they were like pretty skeptical
they did note however on this first
visit
they said one thing they did notice was
that
the relationship between doris and her
sons
was weirdly
contentious
um
she had three sons and uh especially the
ones that were teenagers because she had
one that was 13 and when that was 16
um was really like uh
i don't know if i want to say violent
but it was like really really
contentious
um
barry taft calls it belligerent like the
relationship between them like they
would just like very very aggressively
like yell at each other and stuff
so
there was that
now i will note that i'm not discounting
her claim maybe it you know i'm not
saying i don't i don't think anything's
raped or anything like that but i'm not
like trying to discount her experiences
maybe she did experience something i
don't really know
but i will note that the rapes allegedly
the alleged rapes seemed to stop once
the ambush investigation began so all of
the stuff about the spectral rape that
was just stuff that she reported and
this was before the parapsychologist got
there they didn't see any evidence of
that so the only corroboration of that
that was her and she said she had
bruises and then her son backed her up
on it and said yeah i saw it happening
and then i got thrown against a wall so
there was that so that's all it was was
like word of mouth so i'm not saying it
didn't happen i'm just saying that there
wasn't any like proof of it
so at this point she tells this story
and uh barry and carrie are just kind of
like okay um
we've have made a terrible mistake this
woman is obviously uh delusional
and they're like
so what they did at first
was i don't know how they did this in a
tactful way
but they were like okay well tell you
what uh we have like you know where
where we work at there are some really
good like psychiatrists and maybe we can
like refer you to some of them maybe you
need to talk to someone because you're
obviously having some problems um so
they tried to like do that because they
obviously did not believe her um they
just thought she was trying to get
attention or whatever
um
so there was that
now they thought well should we like
tell the psychiatrist at ucla about her
and they were like well i don't know
like they seem like kind of embarrassed
to like tell them about it like that
we're gonna bring in this like crazy
lady that shanks has been raped by
ghosts
so they're like okay well we'll just
like wait a little bit and see like
what develops and then we'll if anything
else develops we'll like tell them about
it later on
so a few days later
doris called up
called them because they had given uh
given her their card
she calls up and she says you know um
there's five other people here
who are like neighbors and friends of
hers
and they said they saw the apparitions
too
um you know so we have so we have
outside corroboration yeah so at this
point like the parapsychologist is like
okay maybe there's something interesting
going on here so
let's go back with our equipment and
we'll see what we can see oh bless you
sweetie she's over there by my ex she's
playing with the toys
she's sneezing sneezing she's over there
sneezing
well those curtains maybe they're maybe
the curtains are dusty she's always
farting around in the in the curtains
and then she's like
yeah probably dust on the curtains it
was probably like dust on the curtains
but yeah so they tried decided to go
back with their uh equipment
now before they went
stop it folk she's just like sneezing
one head off over there
so before they went um like good
parapsychologists they said okay we're
gonna look into the history of the house
uh you know in the land and see if
there's anything weird going on there
whatever just like you would do
um so they're looking at the background
of the house and the only thing they
could find they said yeah two people had
died there two men
um but they were natural causes so they
said that didn't really seem like
conducive to any kind of like haunting
or anything like that but they just
wanted to check but that was all they
found they did their due diligence
so they go back to the house for their
second visit
and uh you know at first like i said
they did notice that this was kind of uh
like i said colloquially a [ __ ]
but the second time they went back i
think they recognized the extent of
these shitholery like more than they did
the first time yeah um
they're like the the house was made of
wood
and as i mentioned it had been uh
condemned a couple of times
and they're like it was just an
appalling condition
um you know which was kind of a shame
but i mean she was poor what what the
[ __ ] else are you gonna do better than
sleeping in a box
now
but the second uh the second visit um
actually turned out to be like pretty
productive i guess
so the first thing they noticed
they went into doris's bedroom and the
first thing that they uh kind of
perceived was that the temperature in
there was really cold
and they said this was august it was
really hot outside the rest of the house
was hot
but for some reason her bedroom was like
really really cold
um and all the windows were closed and
everything like that so it just seemed
like anomalous like uh you know a
temperature anomaly so it was that
so uh so yeah so cold spots that was the
first thing that they uh kind of noticed
another thing they noticed um upon
entering the bedroom was a very very
strong smell of decomposing flesh they
said it smelled like a morgue in there
pretty much
that was man what i remember him talking
about yeah
kevin says jenny your hair is always
perfect for each episode i like tom
twigs also yeah you like my wig yeah
when he when are you gonna put away
you haven't done that yeah you could do
the wheels it's two hours and fourteen
minutes and you still haven't even like
yeah well it's easy to have perfect hair
when you just slap a wig on although i
do like i do have to brush it and it
does kind of like fly all over the place
so you know what i mean i had my white
one on earlier when i recorded a video
but i don't like i don't like it as much
i think the blue one's still my favorite
but this red one's good too
but yeah so they smelled this horrible
like decomposing flesh smell
and they said that the cold spots and
the
dead smell kind of like wavered in and
out
like it would go away
oh my god i forgot you had that one i
forgot you had the elbow obviously uh
thank you very much for
allowing me to be on the show
oh my god
this wig is ridiculous
i kind of like it though that [ __ ] is
ridiculous jenny
well i mean you need to brush it
obviously
that's the thing about wigs you think
you just like slap it on and it's gonna
you got to brush that [ __ ]
straight up 78 says uh
that's the there's a connection between
the shining and the entity from episode
one and the shining jacket seduced by
that ghost in the bathtub yeah there you
go
um
danny rowling also says the snetaker
haunting the smurl haunting in this case
all to do with ghostly rape which just
fouled up yeah um i don't remember did
we do a show about the snedeker haunting
because that [ __ ] was on
a haunting and paranormal witness
and yeah i think there was some ghostly
rape going on that but the smurl case
was the one with like that was the one
with like the pig creatures raping them
right because i kind of feel like they
were on
not oprah but weren't they on donahue or
geraldo or something they were on like
some [ __ ] talk show like back in the
old days like talking about getting butt
raped by pig creatures
so you know i'm not making that up they
they did actually say that
um so yeah i don't i don't know if we
ever did a show about the smurl haunting
did we
that's a pretty good story
that's a pretty good story i should
probably like write that down i did
write down like the san pedro haunted
because i want to do some [ __ ] about
that but i don't know if i could keep a
straight face like through this moral
heart anything
um
yeah so so yeah cold spots uh dead
people stench and they couldn't really
find they looked for like [ __ ] that
would be causing the smell and they
couldn't find anything
another thing that they noticed when
they came in
was what uh
berrytaff called overpressure
um he describes it as the feeling it's
like um
what it feels like in your inner ear
like you're at the bottom of a deep pool
you know i mean like it pressing on your
ear like that he said so it felt like
that like inside the house
um and then he goes on to say that this
is one of the most common sensations in
cases of like hauntings or poltergeist
activity or something like that that is
the most commonly reported thing is like
this weird feeling of like pressure like
on your inner ear
now this is only the second time they've
been to the house right
so
the first of
many weird things that happened on this
particular evening and this is when
carrie was talking to the oldest son who
was 16 in the kitchen
now carrie was he says he was standing
about a foot away from the lower
cabinets
and then suddenly the cabinet door like
flew open
and a frying pan
flew out of the cabinet
and did like an ark
over about two and a half feet
and hit the floor
right i missed that part was sitting
here
i can't i i can't take you seriously
no i missed that part what what flew
over what was it a pan it was in the
kitchen okay
the cabinet flew open and a pan flew out
yeah and like laying it on the floor it
flew up like in an arc about two and a
half feet okay
like the [ __ ] we saw
yeah so that happened
so the first thing they thought was well
maybe the pan was like leaning against
the cabinet door or something like that
but
you know they they said it didn't really
seem like that because it did actually
like seem to project like quite a long
way like out of the cabinet not just
like it fell out so there was that
so they did an examination of the
cabinet um and
couldn't really find any explanation for
it doing that
so then they go into doris's bedroom
uh there are four of them in there
uh and
dora said that this was where most of
the phenomena took place
now
also in the house this particular
evening was a friend of doris's name
candy now she said that she was psychic
i don't know if that's true or not but
she said she was so there's that
now they had all these cameras with them
so they took a picture of the bedroom
with the polaroid camera and it came out
fine it looked just like the bedroom you
know just like it would
about 15 minutes later they said candy
said that there was something in the
corner of the bedroom
after hearing her shout this uh
dr barry taff runs back into the bedroom
from the kitchen and he
pointed the polaroid where she said
and took a picture
the photograph that came out
was completely
white
as though he says as though exposed to
some powerfully ionizing radiation so it
was just like a completely bleached out
photo even though like i said he had
taken a picture before and it was
completely normal
about 15 minutes after that
candy said again there's something in
the corner i can't she said she couldn't
see it but she could like sense that
something was there nobody could see
anything there
and so he directed his camera again at
the corner and like um took a polaroid
picture
and again the picture was all bleached
out he said it wasn't as bad as the
first one but it was like pretty much
like white over most of it
so
he's like okay well at this point we
decided like we
like yeah it could just be something
with the film like an anomaly i could be
put my thumb in it or something like
that so he's like i'm gonna give the
camera to somebody else to take the
picture they're gonna trade off so it's
just so it's not like one person doing
it
um
so at this point he decides i'm gonna
take another picture of like another
room of the house
so he takes another picture in another
room like almost as a control photo and
this one came out uh completely fine
you know no bleaching no nothing
and then after this
carrie took the polaroid um and took a
picture in the bedroom and in another
room and both of the pictures were
completely normal
now it should be noted that when he took
these pictures candy had not said that
there was anything they only took a
picture the only pictures apparently
that came out like all bleached were
when candy who said she was psychic said
that there was something in the room oh
it's over there and then they took a
picture over there and then the picture
was all whited out when they took
pictures of it just regular the pictures
looked regular as they would
so the next picture that uh that barry
took he was facing the door to the
bedroom
and
he decided to take the picture he said
because he felt like cold air coming
into the room
and there was like a really bad smell
coming in like through the like the the
bedroom door was closed but it was like
coming through like so it was like cold
air and like a stench like coming
through the closed bedroom door so he
decided like to turn the polaroid and
like take a picture
this picture
he said
turned out like
you could see about he said about a few
inches from the floor from the door was
this little
ball of light he said it was about 12
inches in diameter remember the photo
and none of them saw it
at the time that the picture took place
but the pic but the camera picked it up
i remember that photo i remember the
photo he showed there's a lot of weird
photos from this particular i mean that
wasn't even the weirdest one but there's
a lot of weird photos from this [ __ ]
[ __ ] cause they took a [ __ ] done and he
was mad because he said we took photos
of like a lot of [ __ ] that was happening
in front of us and a lot of them didn't
come out
um or didn't come out as weird even
though we were seeing [ __ ] in front of
our face but some of the pictures that
did come out were like super weird but
he said he he made it clear he's like
look i didn't see like a foot
wide like ball of light when i took the
picture
but it was there in the picture you know
what i'm saying that elvis wig didn't
last long did it no no i'm trying
you're tired of that one already yeah
they're hot
yeah tell me about that you're [ __ ]
hot man
and he's complaining about that and you
don't even have any hair like underneath
it i have like all this thick hair like
underneath the wig so i have thick hair
and a wig cap and the wig yeah so it's
like and i wear them for a lot longer
than you do yeah you do so i don't i
don't know what you're complaining about
i'm not completely bad now i mean you
know they're hot and they sometimes they
give me a kind of migraine as well they
usually just give me a headache but i
try not to like if i'm just going to be
on the show
and i'm not going to be dancing because
we're going to slip off i don't because
there's like a clip i don't know if you
guys know if you don't wear wigs but
there's like a clip underneath there to
like keep them from sliding around
and so i'll usually like leave those off
if i'm not going to be dancing around
because you know i don't want them
slipping but
because if you she wears that [ __ ] to
the cliff well yeah but i have to clip
it then but a lot of times it'll give me
a headache because it's like kind of
pinching your head like all night long
but what are you gonna do you know
gotta suffer for beauty i guess
or you know whatever it is
so okay
so at this point like they're kind of
like freaking out they're looking at
this picture going holy [ __ ] look at
that
[ __ ]
and then barry says
uh that he looked over toward the one of
the bedroom's windows
and he saw a whole bunch of electric
blue
balls of light like moving around like
rapidly
so he picks up the polaroid
and takes a picture like in the
direction of the curtain
now this picture he said came out really
blurry and really really bleached like
bleached white
now
he says that at this point the only
light that was on the overhead light
wasn't on they didn't have any lamps on
or anything they said the only like
illumination in the room was like a
candle
and the flash bulbs of the cameras that
were going off they didn't have any
other lights on so he says there's
really no reason why this photo should
have been whited out he was trying to
take a picture of these supposedly like
moving electric blue lights but he
didn't get it it was just like all
bleached out
now a little while later candy who like
again the the claimed psychic
she says there's something standing
right in front of me
so barry like aims the polaroid
and the way the picture came out he said
this one was really weird too
he said he took a picture of her
because she said there was something
right in front of her
he said her face in the picture is
completely whited out
but
her
dress and the background like the
curtains and stuff like that are
completely fine it was just her face
that was whited out
so he thought that was kind of weird too
a little while later candy again says
there's something right in front of me
so carrie took the picture this time
and it came out about the same as the
previous one got the curtains in the
background got her outfit
everything like that but her face was
all wiped out like bleached out which
they thought was very strange
and
the thing about it too was that a couple
minutes later carrie who had not moved
took another picture with the same
polaroid like as a control
um he asked her like candy he asked
candy he's like is it gone now and she
said yeah
so he took another picture like without
moving and the
photograph that he took after that came
out completely normal
um so there was that
so
pretty much like whenever she said hey
there's something in the room and they
took a picture they got a weird photo
and whenever she said oh there's nothing
in here or nobody was thinking about it
and they took a picture the pictures
came out normal that's what they're
saying
so at this point carrie gives barry the
polaroid
now he was gonna put it on the dresser
um
he wanted to see how many pictures were
left in the camera he said
and
while he was walking over to the dresser
like to put it down he was kind of
looking at the camera to see like how
many pictures were left on it and he
said that it took a picture by itself
um he said my hand was not on the button
or anything like that
uh it just took a picture by itself and
spit it out
and the picture that it spit out was
just completely
black
which
he said was weird because you'd think it
would have taken a picture of like you
know the floor or the wall or something
like that because it was just like
normal light in the room but it didn't
the picture was just completely black
there was nothing on it
so there was that
and that was like the end of the second
night so they left after that
now the third night they came back um
and this was about a week after
the the second night the previous uh
time they'd been there
now at this point it was barry and
carrie and then this other like
photographer who was from a camera shop
in brentwood
now this woman the photographer came
into doris's bedroom and immediately
said the smell in here is making me sick
to my stomach she said it doesn't smell
like [ __ ] dead people that's what it
smells like
so
this is pretty much this third time that
they came to the house is pretty much
the first time that they all saw
identical visual phenomena
he says on more than 20 separate
occasions all of us present in the
bedroom including doris and the female
photographer
simultaneously observed what appeared to
be small pulsing flashes of light that's
what he said
now the room
was kind of dark they said they just had
a couple candles in there that's about
it
and to
make sure that like the light wasn't
coming from the outside like they didn't
want it to be like reflections from
outside like headlights or anything or
sunlight or anything like that so what
they had done was they had taken a bunch
of quilts and blankets and [ __ ] like
that like hung them all over the windows
they're trying to like black out the
room as much as possible to kind of get
rid of like outside stimuli
now
the thing about it was that they said
when we did that then the lights inside
the room like if anything they looked
brighter because there wasn't anything
else to like compare them again so
they're like at that point we knew that
it wasn't coming from outside because
they were like well we had to
you know you have to get rid of the
possibility that it could just be like
reflected headlights from outside and
they're like it uh it obviously was not
that because we had all the windows and
everything covered up and it was still
happening and you could actually like
see it better now that it was like
really dark in the room
so uh so there was that
now
so it's all of these kind of they've
done like reenactments of it and he
basically described it he's like they
were just like these little you know
what people say it's orbs and a lot of
times like
you know when people say pictures orb
that their mother
most [ __ ] are talking about
i've seen the photo
it's like a glowing ball of flame like
plasma
a lot of times when they say orbs oh
look at that orb it's just a piece of
dust and this looks like a bug or
something yeah but when you look at the
photographs at the shell it looks more
like kind of like yeah this isn't like
that more kind of like a place where a
laser beam is hidden
kind of like that
and he did say that it looked like
plasma like a plastic that's what he
said
um
and he said everybody saw them and they
were like moving around like these balls
of light were like moving around like
inside the room
um so there was that but there was a and
the thing about him they said is it was
really hard to get them like on film
which i'll get into a little bit you
know some of the photos that they took
like they did kind of get them on film
although they don't look like balls they
look like streaks
yeah i mean well they did have like high
they did have high speed cameras and if
it infrared they had all that stuff they
had like good [ __ ] but they said that
it was just weird that it came out like
that but they said what we were seeing
was balls of light that looked like
plasma like 3d like balls that's what it
looked like
now they didn't really get a lot of
photos on this third visit even though
they did see a lot of light anomalies um
they took a bunch of pictures uh they
had a polaroid they had a 35 millimeter
with infrared film in it um but they
didn't really get anything they said
they were frustrated because they were
seeing all this crazy [ __ ] but like when
they tried to take a picture of it it
wasn't once more yeah but it wasn't like
coming out you know what i mean and they
even were like
they tried to record it they said what
what they did
was they had these like x-ray dental
tabs and they kind of like put them
around the rooms or around the room and
then they had like a sheet of 8x10 film
which was kind of uh they put it in
between this like radiation intensifying
plates because they were trying to like
pick up the ship but they couldn't like
get anything on it so they weren't
really sure
what was producing these light anomalies
because a lot of times it was like
really weird like what would turn up on
camera and what wasn't
um
but they said that they were
they were all seeing them they said they
either look like balls of light or
sometimes like triangles but i think
normally they said they just look like
big balls of light
now uh they found out the next day that
the female photographer that had been
there that had complained about the
smell
she said after she uh went home that the
smell had made her so sick that she was
like throwing up like all night long so
there was that
so the fourth visit that they did um
this was kind of like this was again a
week later
what they wanted to do on this
particular night was do like a seance
which he even says is not like the best
idea but we just like wanted to see what
would happen
so they decided to do a seance they
wanted to see if they could like talk to
whatever was like doing this
so they said the people in the seance
that were doing the sands it was eight
people and then they had like another 10
people that were like watching so like
this is not like just a one or two
people this is a bunch of people because
they had
the couple parapsychologists um i think
a couple doris's friends were there like
a couple of doors kids were there and
then they had like a bunch of like
volunteers from the parapsychology lab
at ucla so you know as
as like word got around that all this
stuff was going on like a lot of them
wanted to come to see it like also they
would get like you know photography
experts and they would get like people
like that so some of the stuff that got
witnessed it was like a lot of people
he's like sometimes it would be like 20
25 people like in the room that were
seeing all the [ __ ] at the same time so
there was that so they're doing this uh
seance and like i said there's
like 18 people
you know a couple dozen people
there at the same time
um most of the spectators he said had
cameras uh they said they had infrared
film they had high speed [ __ ] they had
like strobes they had everything
now on this particular night he said
they saw what looked to be like really
really intense
lights
and they said they were very clearly
three-dimensional
um
and they would like change size
you know like get bigger and smaller and
get more intense and less intense
[ __ ] like that and they couldn't really
figure out
if
they were trying to like figure out ways
that you know if somebody would start
like trying to produce these like
fraudulently how you would do that
they're like really the only way that
you'd be able to do that was like with
like some sophisticated laser system and
it's like they didn't really think that
anybody in the house had the technical
know-how like to know how to do that
um because they're like obviously
everyone was seeing them and they looked
like they were three-dimensional
so uh so there was that um now the
the thing about it he says they're kind
of like
sometimes they'd be like really small
but he's like sometimes they'd go really
big and it would be like the whole
corner of the room and [ __ ] like
that now at this point he says
doris's uh 16 year old son
said to the investigators
you know uh before you guys were here
he's like we used to think it was well i
don't know if they thought it was funny
but there's like there's certain albums
that we used to play
that used to in his words infuriate
the
entities or whatever they were
these albums were uh
black sabbath
album and uri heap
uh whenever you played those in the
house
like the
the phenomena would like ramp way the
[ __ ] up because apparently either the
ghost like really dug it or really did
not dig it
um because he's like yeah we we we used
to like play them and like the you know
it would get like really crazy in here
now both of the songs that were
mentioned by the oldest son like were
kind of like songs that kind of
specifically like mentioned the devil or
had like words about the devil so they
kind of like made a lot of that but i
don't know how much that has to do with
anything
but they just noticed that it that when
they played these particular songs at
these particular albums that like the
ghost would kind of like flip out and
like do crazy [ __ ]
so there's that
so they were like okay well we're gonna
do that so they decided they were gonna
play these particular songs and indeed
when they played those particular songs
off this particular albums
the weird lights like increased
dramatically
um and seemed to almost kind of like go
along with the music like it was
responding to it which they thought was
like really interesting
so tom missed that whole thing yeah you
keep like wandering off and like missing
stuff
the ghosts were like play some blue play
circle skinnard
well i remember this case before what
part were you talking about i was
talking about how how the ghost would
react more to like uh particular songs
by black sabbath and uriah heap oh i
don't remember that
i remember that part
the uriah heap
well
the sun said that the sun said that then
it's like when we played particular
songs off those albums like the light
activity would like ramp way up and so
they said okay well let's do that and
they did that and they said yeah that's
indeed what happened like the light
started like flashing why are you rya
heap
that was a damn i don't know mediocre
band at best okay i don't know maybe the
ghosts like really liked them i don't
know just like you're right or they
don't or they didn't really like them
i'm not entirely sure
okay
so
so while this light activity like ramped
up
um
they had
you know everybody there pretty much
everybody there had cameras and they
were all trying to like catch something
so they're all like taking pictures like
the whole time
they had a whole bunch of polaroids they
had three 35-millimeter cameras and they
were just like kept taking pictures like
towards the lights that they saw
um
but most of the photos didn't come out
like didn't show anything like
significant one picture though
came out uh interesting they said
they got one picture and this he says
specifically this was taken with um the
the film was kodak tri-x black and white
film
with a deep red filtered strobe he's
like that was the only one that captured
anything
even though everybody was taking
pictures and they all saw it apparently
this picture shows what looks to be like
a little ball of light like flying
across the corner of the room
and he said it looked kind of like a
comet with a tail behind it i've seen
the photo he said the problem with it
though is that there's nothing in the
background like the background is just
black so you can't really tell like
there's no like context yeah no kind of
for what size it is or what size and and
he was like well that was a problem so
later they tried to like rectify that
like with some other stuff that they did
in the room let me just say in general i
remember these photos since i was a kid
and i was let me run to the bathroom
yeah pretty much i've only seen them in
black and white from inside of books
paranormal books
they
they're not obviously fakes
okay
they could be real but they're hard to
tell everything's kind of ambiguous
one of the ones that i really remembered
was
some of that light phenomena like plasma
up uh on the wall up near the floor
right above the carpet
it looks like little balls of light
today it would look like places where a
[ __ ] um regular visible laser would
be hidden there might be like one or two
and three they're different sizes one
next to the other just like
hitting near where the the floorboards
are up here you know where it meets the
carpet it's hitting right about there
you can see some reflected light around
it
but you just that was in an era where
lasers were real expensive
they were about that big and about that
tall and they cost thousands of dollars
it wasn't like you could just go down a
walmart and get a 99 cent
laser emitter on the end of a keychain
it's you know it was that era was not
around yet
so i don't think they had a laser
to uh
to fake that
was it faked by something on negatives i
i don't know it looked like it was a
real phenomena of some sort
and you're not talking about digital
photography it was analog
using film
which kind of had a little bit of
different effects because you could [ __ ]
around with exposure times and stuff
the to me the photos were inconclusive
they were they looked weird they did
they are weird-looking but it's hard to
tell what it is yeah it's hard to tell
what it is
um
now having seen poultry guys phenomenal
myself and you know been kind of like
the focus of it over i guess [ __ ] it was
mostly just a couple months
but um
that's where the most intense activity
but really over it's been my whole
lifetime off and on now
this does sound like a poltergeist event
well that's what barry taft thought yeah
that's what it sounds like
um
well he said that 95 99 of the stuff he
investigated
even though people thought it was
haunting was poltergeist guys yeah which
is rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis and this woman is the
focus which that's kind of unusual
because usually it would be a person
like me somebody going through puberty
at the time i mean you're not going
through puberty right now but when it
happened
when it was really good
i mean we've had stuff happen recently
but it's a little [ __ ] you know
and it doesn't scare me like it used to
you know but uh it's rspk now all this
stuff about seeing figures and the rapes
and [ __ ] yeah plausible
but that's not what it is it's not
ghosts it's
from her subconscious or unconscious
these are characters that she's brought
to life using psychokinesis kind of like
in the same way when you're in a dream
you can get attacked by characters in
your dream
as if they're an outside force but
they're not they're you
they're you attacking you that's just
your brain yeah
[ __ ] with you yeah your conscious
mind is not the only mind that's in
there just ask jenny she sees me all the
time there's three or four of them and
they're fighting constantly because more
than that i would think yeah there's a
bunch up in their fight but the the
the mind is a
just like what skinny puppy said in that
album that album [ __ ] called mind the
perpetual intercourse your mind is
nothing but just a conversation of a
bunch of different facets trying to
figure out what to do the decisions were
made long before your conscious mind
ever even [ __ ] knows about it
all proven by brain science they've gone
in there and scanned it and they go you
know what
he had already decided to do that the
misconception rationalized it as if it
was its idea
but they could look inside the mris that
you'd already reached that conclusion
long before you even knew about it
it's wild
but let me ask you this
let me give you an example
sometimes something will fall off a
table and you'll catch it before you
even realize that it fell
or i was on my bike [ __ ]
down at an angle applying a bunch of
throttle and lost my front end and it
started to go into [ __ ] losing the
front end and i don't even know how i
got out of it
but other
other aspects of your mind [ __ ]
did what they had to do
to keep the bike running before you even
know even aware of it really
um
mentioned in star wars the [ __ ]
obi-wan puts the [ __ ]
blaster shields on [ __ ]
luke and he's able to [ __ ] stop the
[ __ ] bolts from the remote without
even knowing he's just allowing it to
flow because there's certain areas in
your mind that are
a lot better than the conscious mind
well you have to think that i mean the
the part of your brain
that is kind of like your higher self if
you want to say like your frontal lobe
and all that because that's a later
edition yeah um a lot of the [ __ ] that's
like your your reptilian brain if you
want to call it that is much older and
better at a lot of things i mean
depending on what it is but sometimes it
can be better at those type of things at
physicality it's a lot better
and sensing well that's why they always
kind of tell you like look if you feel
really really strong like really really
bad about that yeah like you shouldn't
fall your gut on everything because that
would be dumb but in some like
situations if you feel like if you feel
like you're walking down the street and
you feel like suddenly there's somebody
back there and you feel like you're in
danger from that person you probably are
then probably you should listen to that
probably you should listen to that
because that's you know
jenny says don't always listen to your
gut i would say listen to your gut about
95 of the time
um
the other more primitive areas of your
brain
are much older
and they have been through millions of
years of evolution they're a lot older
than the frontal lobes when it comes to
reason and consciousness
all right they are a lot more tested
um they're more tested and they've been
more reinforced in the gene pool
[ __ ] like reasoning it out and this and
that that's only for certain tasks when
it's safe well i guess it depends on
what it depends on the situation
but the default setting is follow your
gut
follow your gut
sometimes you can detect
you can detect treachery and deception
yeah i mean if something feels bad to
you
i mean you should probably listen to it
usually you should probably listen to
that don't be all this oh well you know
i feel bad about this but i'm just no
this is this is just my prejudices
against this and that no listen to your
[ __ ] gut because every one of them
girls that got into a damn [ __ ] car
with a serial killer because she was
selling booty she probably had a bad
feeling about the dude but she's like
well well and the thing about it and
it's this is shitty too and i was gonna
bring this up is that culturally yeah uh
women in particular are kind of like
socialized to
not one not listen to their feelings
because you kind of get that oh you're
just being silly or you're just
overthinking it or blah blah and it's so
you're and you're also kind of like
socialized to be like people pleasers
like don't be rude don't go that way
don't um you know don't cause conflict
or don't like upset anybody or something
like that so a lot of people like a lot
of women particularly don't want to like
even if somebody is creeping them out
big time they don't want to seem mean or
they don't want to seem like you know uh
you know they just don't want to like be
rude to that person even if that person
is creeping them out and a lot of times
that will get you in trouble very much
so a lot of times that we get in trouble
yeah listen to your instincts i mean if
somebody is creeping you out there's
probably a reason of course there's a
reason there's that person is putting
out all kinds of [ __ ] body language
and unconscious signals
that your unconscious mind is picking it
up from the animal kingdom and giving
you certain feelings about this dude is
sketchy
okay
he is sketchy that's why you feel that
way just run away just get you it
doesn't matter [ __ ] it doesn't matter if
it's rude it doesn't matter if it's
embarrassing just get the [ __ ] out of it
you might get murdered you might not but
it's like why do you want to stick
around to find out
you don't know that dude anytime i'm
[ __ ] in my routine and some dudes
coming up and giving me something that's
kind of out of the ordinary and i'm
going like well you know what
what this person is asking for this
really isn't in my favor
it's not my favor to do what this guy
says
it's more in this guy's favor ah nah get
the [ __ ] out here and then turns out
later yeah the [ __ ] is con in
you okay
that's just the way it is be
street smart be it's the animal kingdom
okay go with your feelings
all right
some people don't have those feelings
they're just too damn domesticated but
they've been i think most people have
those they have them for it's just that
a lot of times
not to listen well a lot of times yeah
you've been taught not to listen to it
well like i said uh just unlearn what
you have learned that's what you had to
say like i said this happens a lot
particularly like i said to a lot of
girls because it's like there's like oh
you have to be why don't you be nice and
why don't you because girls don't want
to be [ __ ] and they don't want to be
rude and all this other kind of stuff
like now that i'm old i don't give a
[ __ ] about being rude anymore
but it's just kind of like
but when i was younger i absolutely
probably would i don't think i would
have gotten a car with a serial killer
but
um you know you kind of like talk
yourself out of it oh it can't be yeah
i'm just being silly i'm just being
silly yeah i just know you're not and
well and it's not just you it's like
other people tell you that too like you
tell people like i felt this that
they're like oh you're overreacting
you're doing this and that so there's a
lot of like gaslighting going on too
that kind of like reinforces oh i must
be i'm just imagining things yeah but so
there's that's it there's other dopes
that are telling you that you're
overreacting though
in my opinion
usually in my experience it's just other
dopes saying that well and it's really
easy for people to tell you that you're
overreacting when they when they weren't
there there and they weren't in your
shoes
when they weren't there right i mean i
remember very particularly one time who
like before i had a car and i used to
have to walk everywhere and this was i
was walking to a client that i was um
freelancing for
and it was daylight it was i didn't walk
around like at night by myself or
anything like that i'm not that crazy
but um you know so i was just walking in
the day and some dude like pulls over
and is like trying to hey you want to
ride somewhere somebody like that and i
was just kind of like
nope nope but it's like running the [ __ ]
away from that dude i didn't you know
what and i was like pretty young i
didn't want to be rude but then i was
like why am i worried about being rid i
don't know this [ __ ] dude yeah he's
trying to get you in the car with him i
was just like to quit don't worry about
being rude yeah [ __ ] off you don't know
that
i don't know you like i'm not gonna lose
anything by being like rude to you i
mean they might like shoot you in the
face maybe but probably not
not broad daily
um yeah so
a dip
where was it somebody just asked me was
it you danny why are you retracting all
your messages
did you just ask did they really freeze
the ghost
like in the movie no
that was um and that was like the issue
that i had with the movie and honestly i
love the entity it's a really good movie
if you haven't seen it from 1982 in case
you don't know um but yeah the [ __ ]
about like freezing the ghost and so
yeah that didn't happen that didn't
happen and that was uh my biggest issue
with the movie i was like why did the
[ __ ] they do that it just seemed like
the story was good enough on its own you
could have just made a movie with that
i mean
freezing a ghost just seems like really
really silly it seems very silly
so no that did not happen
that did not happen
so
yeah so where was i okay so they were
taking pictures and none of them really
came out or they were frustrated because
they're like look we're seeing all this
crazy [ __ ] but the photos don't seem to
be coming out or don't seem to be like
capturing it and they were getting
frustrated
now they did have some photos though
that seemed to look like
they were kind of like maybe like
figures or faces or something like that
that were kind of like
outlined in light sort of like against
this particular closet door
but barry admits like in his own account
he's like look these pictures are
they're not super clear it's like yeah
if you're looking at them looking for a
face or a figure then yeah that's what
it looks like but it could also be a
rorschach test kind of situation
so i don't really like to like show
these to people as like oh here's proof
or anything because it they could be
other things
but he's like we did see all this crazy
[ __ ] but the cameras weren't capturing
them but he's like so there's that
but i don't know if theirs were like
true or not even though that's kind of
what it looked like
so
so there was that now
so the fifth time they went back to
doris's house
and they said this time this was like a
big time uh kind of escalation like in
what was going on
so because they were mad because the
photo that they got before with like the
weird comet like thing that they thought
was cool but it's like well there's no
context so they said okay well we need
to like sort that out so what they did
was they went around doris's room and
they said we're they taped like black
poster board like all over all of her
windows and uh you know walls and
everything and they said we used this
like industrial
like uh like aircraft tape
and they did it like they measured it
all out so it was like a grid so it's
like so we could see like what size
everything like all around the walls and
everything so they did that
um
you know so they could like number
everything and like say what quadrant
this happened in and what size it was
and everything like that
um so because the the boards were black
but the tape was white
so they used that like as a reference so
they used they sealed off all the light
sources and everything like that
now they said at this point the fifth
visit there were
uh
more than 30 people
in the house observing all of this stuff
some of them uh volunteers there were
photographers all kind of different
people were were in there
now they said on this particular
occasion uh they saw all the same lights
again and they were brighter than they
were before
and at this point
the lights began to respond to their
verbal suggestions yeah i remember this
part of the story yeah
they said they uh reacted and responded
to our jokes
and various provoking remarks especially
those made by doris they said she would
like make some kind of like she would
swear at them or like yeah one man
[ __ ] whatever because one of the
things i don't know if you guys remember
but one of the things that they thought
was interesting was that doris i don't
think she was an alcoholic but
um
sometimes if she drank a lot
like the uh the phenomena would like
ramp up
so they wondered if there was some kind
of like correlation
between her being drunk and with the
phenomenon reducing her conscious
inhibitions that's what i'm that's what
i was thinking yeah that's what i was
thinking yeah i'm interested to find out
when i was back then when my poltergeist
was [ __ ] doing his thing what would
happen if i'd gotten drunk
that'd be some weird [ __ ] it might have
just went dormant but in her case it
probably you know it acted up
yeah okay weird yeah and they said a lot
of weird theory people i think whatever
you see during poltergeist activity
that's actually a an exotic form of
physics
that would be could be used in space
travel
a lot of things you hear about ufo
cases
kind of sound like something out of
poltergeist
weird movement teleportation type stuff
probably what it is you may be able to
make a machine that does this
i mean it sounds crazy but electricity
was at one time considered to be
paranormal
true back in the [ __ ] 14 years it is
weird when you think about it
back in the 14 or 1500s this person
would see a spark and they would think
that that they got witnessed by an angel
because they saw a [ __ ] spark
because a spark would be like [ __ ]
which is funny nowadays but if you cast
yourself back to that mindset yeah it's
easy to think yeah easy to see how they
would think that right they're like did
you see that that was an angel it saw it
it was looking at us yeah
so because they didn't know what it was
do you know what it was they didn't know
what it was yeah
so i think poltergeist activity is
something like that
like electricity but a new form it's
something natural
we just don't know don't understand what
it is yet um that's kind of where i'm at
with that yeah yeah there's like much
weirder [ __ ] that still has to be
discovered and when you figure out what
it is it would be like oh and maybe like
a hundred years from now it won't even
be exotic yeah it's gonna be something
like boring it's gonna end up falling
into like the category of like zero
point energy or
something having to do with that uh
mind
mind can control matter because mind and
matter and perception are all kind of
part of a certain singularity that's in
another dimension you know it's just
it's going to be something that some
egghead will figure out
you know
like oh yeah that's all it is don't [ __ ]
on the egg i'm not talking about bad
about these man they figure everything
out yeah yeah they're the reason that
you have a comfortable life nowadays
yeah yeah of course
[Laughter]
don't [ __ ] on smart people i'm not
talking about you
somebody had to figure it out to go oh
that's all it is if you look at
something sideways like that it does
this
reality is how you look at it it's going
to be something like a schrodinger's cat
type situation you know it's going to be
quantum physics
zero-point energy type deal and
that sorry reality isn't as real as you
think it is and that if you change the
perspective on the [ __ ] object that
the the the aspect of the object changes
it's going to be something like that
lyrica dude says who you gonna call
frigidaire
danny rowling says oh my god i love this
idea some blue frozen ghost pops would
have been good marketing idea to promote
the film just saying yeah because
because he was asking earlier if uh if
they'd actually frozen the ghost like
liked the movie now
that was that was really that's the
fictional part of the damn movie that
was really frustrating i really wish
they hadn't gone in that direction
i don't know i must let them in the
restaurant i mean dr barry taff was like
pretty pissed off about that too he's
like look the the real story was cool
enough i don't know why you guys had to
like go there with that because like
that didn't even happen but whatever
yeah and that was like
it seemed like up till then it was
scarier because it was like believable
still but when you went in that
direction i was just kind of like come
on now
you're freezing the ghost frozen ghosts
come on now that's ridiculous ridiculous
but you know what are you gonna do
so so yeah so as i said they actually
said okay so the lights apparently
were responding to [ __ ] that they said
and like questions that they asked
so they said like doris would be like
swearing and [ __ ] at them and it would
like blink or whatever and they actually
said out loud
um
hey let's
you know we're gonna ask you questions
and you you know you have to blink this
many times for yes and this many times
for now you know what i mean and they
said the lights actually did respond
to their questions
you know
so
at that point they were just kind of
like because i mean dr taft seems to
think still
that he he's like he's pretty sure that
this was like you know rspk that this is
he's like 95 of the time that's what it
is
but he's like at this at this point i
was kind of like questioning myself
because i wasn't sure because it was
responding to our questions in this way
we weren't sure if it was some kind of
what he called a like a discarnate
intelligence meaning like a ghost
essentially yeah
um i don't think he believes that um he
pretty much said later i'm pretty sure
it's not that but he just thought this
was really interesting that it responded
to their questions like in real time
like by flashing like answers at them
hugo asked me a question what's that
asking if i think that the poltergeist
is nothing but a manifestation of a
person's energy i would say yes
i i certainly believe that because i
lived through it
and you got to look at it this way
jenny wrote a book called unseen hand
oh there's a she dug up a lot of cases
from the past that all support this all
right
one of the ones that i remember reading
about a long time ago when i was about
16 or 17 when i was researching it after
my [ __ ] happened
i don't know if it's in the book but it
took place in japan
uh in like 1700s
there's the tokugawa period
a young japanese
girl who was a servant in somebody's
house
wherever she was things like little pots
and pans and dishes would fly up and
jump around and sometimes dance
uh expensive pieces of silk would get
ripped down the middle
by an unseen force in front of a bunch
of other people
wherever she went there was kind of like
this weird presence around her as if
there was a presence that had extended
outside of her body
the guy that owned the house who was a
uh
kind of a high level [ __ ] japanese
guy
brought in an investigator who was of
the samurai class and he investigated it
for about a week or so
and he came to the conclusion that the
girl
because of frustrations had an imbalance
in her chi force
all right and the imbalance in the chi
force he was using taoism and taoism and
eastern philosophy
had her frustrations had caused an
imbalance in her chief force and this is
nothing but her energy doing this
without her even knowing about it
he's talking about the force
that's exactly what
george lucas was talking about with the
light side the dark side of the force
and yin and yang force that's that's
what that's where star wars came from
and
lucas got all that [ __ ]
from um
from uh what's his name uh uh campbell
his
joseph campbell his teacher the
university there who wrote a bunch of
books himself
and these stories go way back
is there chi i don't know
there's something like that there's
something like chi or there's something
like the force or psychic energy or life
energy or soul energy or zero point
energies
humans are going to come up with all
these kind of weird names for it and for
some reason
people that have
consciousness can alter
things in the environment
there's evidence but under rare
circumstances what they can do without
touching it
it's just uh rspk that's what the uh
parapsychologist came out recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis
so even back
in the 1700s
a japanese dude who was educated
he came up with a good hypothesis that i
think still stands
because she was frustrated
her life force was doing this without
her knowing about it that's rspk
yeah danny rowling said wasn't she
sexually abused by her father and family
which totally could have triggered a
poltergeist yeah um story was that doris
bither or by theory if you prefer uh had
been the um
the victim of a lot of abuse maybe not
maybe not from her family like but maybe
um but she'd also had like several
boyfriends apparently that had abused
her so she had a lot of problems and she
had a lot of trauma and that was
something that dr barry taff was like
looking into because he's like well this
is kind of like even though she's older
than your classic poltergeist focus but
because she'd had such
trauma in her life and because he noted
specifically
that she had such a contentious
relationship
with her three
sons
and he thought it was interesting
that her
alleged uh sexual abuse by the spirits
was three spirits and she's like and she
had three sons that she had a really
contentious relationship with so he was
thinking that maybe she was like
projecting that or like making that
happen yeah because of her weird
relationship with them
i i agree with uh the old samurai do
from the 1700s it's frustration
but it's not real common because it has
to be from a person that has a lot of
internal discipline
who doesn't show the frustration so they
keep it bottled up it has to escape
somewhere and and sometimes it escapes
as this poltergeist activity
and there were a lot of psycho
parapsychologists even back in the 70s
in the 60s in california where i grew up
who would have agreed with this
taft is probably one of them because
he's from that's tapped with two deaths
not taft like the fabric okay
taff would probably agree with me he's
from that same air place in time and
there were a lot of guys that were into
this [ __ ]
dr penner and [ __ ] everything you
know from lois who's my aunt
the guys that she worked for she knew
about this you know she was with palomar
palomar observatory she worked with
those guys and when she told them the
story they were like at first they
didn't believe her her boss
dr petter and then he came back a couple
days later he says i wanted to he goes i
want to he's like lewis i want to
apologize what you're talking about yeah
we do know about that that's called
poltergeist and that's the first time i
ever heard that word when lois came back
and
told us yeah it was called poltergeist
activity
and they knew about it but they didn't
know what it was or why well they still
don't they still don't know
john gore says eggheads can be
sociopaths too yeah but so can dumbasses
oh yeah more likely a dumbass i think
it's more likely a dumbass it's going to
be a sociopath so i i don't i don't know
like i said correlation when you got a
smart sociopath then you have something
like a world leader
yeah they rust then you gotta look out
luckily for us most sociopaths are
dumbass yeah right so they get caught
eventually well like i kind of feel like
most people in general are dumbasses
so you know what i mean
uh let's see oh blair the dude says if
this is true how come this stuff does
not happen more often
i kind of feel like maybe if it's true
and i don't know if it is but it just
seems like if it is true
it maybe it just has to be a particular
you know like serial killers for example
it has to be like a perfect storm it's a
perfect storm of everything having to
come together just right i talked about
it before in other shows
you can't be
so smart that you rationalize yourself
out of it but you can't be so dumb
you have to come from a background that
has faith and the idea and the belief in
that scene lets me out so it has to be
kind of a religious background
you have to be [ __ ]
in a uh
family where there's a lot of turmoil in
my case it was divorce divorce and
conflict all right
uh you have to have a lot of inner
discipline so you can't act out on it
um
then you have to have um
extended family involved
uh that uh can can allow for an outlet
uh there can't be social media so that
way you're because the person has to be
socially isolated with no outlets like
nobody to talk nobody to talk to right
so there's a lot of factors the the the
fact
social media
has probably prevented a lot of it well
we talked about activity i mean the
we've talked about social media
preventing like stuff like the classic
serial killer kind of cases before
and i think this is maybe the same
situation i'm not equating like people
that experience poltergeist activities
but i'm just saying just in the sense of
like rarity and in the sense of it being
having to be like a particular
confluence of factors
that doesn't happen as much anymore it's
frustration and inhibition
you have to have that
or well it won't work now there's
another way you can do it
based in my experience transcendental
meditation
you go down the other path of trying to
induce an out-of-body experience through
astral projection
okay because when i absolutely projected
and i only did it once
poltergeist activity [ __ ]
broke out around the room during the
time where i exteriorized
and that was weird because my roommate
[ __ ] pulled me back in by [ __ ]
shaking me and bringing me back in
then later on i had a near-death
experience in a motorcycle accident it
was only like a week later
all right
so there was a there was a link there
because i tried
to astrally project or to exteriorize
because i don't like the word [ __ ]
astral projection that's some new age
bulls i tried to exteriorize where to
move my consciousness my point of view
outside of my own physical body
and every time trying to do it negates
it you have to allow it
and it's a total surrender it's like
it's kind of feels like
voluntary death to allow yourself to die
by natural processes is what it feels
like
you can't have any fear you just got to
go into it
and i've never really been able to do it
again every time i've done it before
right around a time where it feels like
i'm coming out i'll lose consciousness i
don't remember what happened like fall
asleep
feels like a head's shaking back and
forth and all of a sudden you're looking
down on yourself
and then you're out that's what it felt
like
first time i did it
it's weird
john gore says david lynch is a big
transcendental meditation guy yeah yeah
that seems like yeah he's rolling now
he's real into like this we'll be honest
you take some psychotropic drugs
lsd maybe or tmt
and then you do transcendental
meditation there's a good chance where
you might be able to exteriorize
might be easier
well it's getting rid of some of the
roadblocks yeah i think is what is
i mean the value of that yeah now
[ __ ] very light does the morphine
might do it
because that would also alleviate fear
that might do it
and there are other people that have
said that it's worked
uh but you know it's on you but i mean
if if this is something that people can
do whether you're just perceiving it
like whether it's some weird anomaly of
your brain that you're just perceiving
it or whether it's actually happening
um obviously most people are going to be
like afraid to do that because it's like
you're dying yeah that's [ __ ] up and
like it's very natural to be like afraid
of dying yeah so getting rid of that
fear
that might predicate
you know i gotta take some drugs to like
alleviate that the fear
and then it will happen yeah
that's my theory i have never tried it
i mean that seems pretty reasonable yeah
to me yeah i think maybe a little dose
of morphine gets you [ __ ] high
you know what i mean
and then you go into transcendental
meditation we don't care if you live or
die that would probably help
and then once you're out you're not
you're not constrained by the [ __ ]
normal biology so
because you
and the drugs don't matter you're just
trying to release yourself from the body
i know it can happen i've done it
but it was spontaneous
i didn't really try to do it right it
happened it on its own but that's kind
of like your whole thing is that you
can't really you can't trust like if you
try to do it then you're gonna [ __ ] it
up because trying trying when you try to
do something that's your that's
conscious right right right you're now
applying will and to apply will it
[ __ ] reinforces
consciousness and you're not trying
you're trying to lose it
you're trying to go to sleep without
losing consciousness basically and it
will
release yourself from your body
and effort can get in the way of that
you have to release
a good example i say is a [ __ ]
you're sitting there trying to [ __ ]
take a piss and a motherfucker's looking
at you
somebody's looking at you well you're
trying to die but you are looking at
yourself so you're stopping it from
happening you have to [ __ ] just
release
and die
you won't but you have to have the you
have to have the [ __ ]
faith that you won't physically die that
your body will remain alive i mean it's
not being harmed you have an autonomic
nervous system it'll continue to breathe
your heart will continue to beat there's
no damage
let it out
you know
but it's easier said than done yeah it's
only happened once
with me well twice the second time was a
motorcycle accident
and that was that was a near death that
was nde yeah that was not ob that's very
difficult you were in a coma i was in a
coma right
but i left before the accident ever
happened
i saw myself
on the bike going i never before the
right before the wreck i never even saw
the wreck i was already in heaven then
the bite then the bike and the body
continued on to go into the intersection
and get hit by the car yeah yeah i
wasn't even there i was going on talking
to ancestors and talking to [ __ ]
spiritual friends and they're like come
up here for a second the bad shit's
about to happen yeah well no they were
going like oh i remember i remember you
i remember you and oh yeah i loved you
too and all this kind of [ __ ] you know
and i got these lord of the rings
[ __ ] talking to me and [ __ ] and then
lord of the rings [ __ ] yeah well one
of them looked like elves and [ __ ] yeah
elves and stuff talking you know i know
i know and they're all different sizes
and the [ __ ] the big ones watching me
and i don't know if it's a if it's a
super ego or a god or whatever it didn't
even matter everybody was familiar and
then they go guess what
you got to go back
it's not your time
i was like no no no no no no but it's so
awesome up here
no you got to do this and that they're
showing me things
and i'm going oh yeah he's still got all
this [ __ ] yeah yeah i forgot about that
i forgot oh my god
and it was like about a week later i got
so much [ __ ] yeah i forgot about that
right
because it was it's like a movie i
already agreed to watch
it's kind of like me waking up at five
in the morning going oh [ __ ] i got so
much [ __ ] i gotta do stuff yeah right
yeah every day yeah and what was funny
is that it's not serious yeah it's not
serious none of it is serious you agreed
to all this
you're like oh yeah yeah i forgot yeah
yeah
that's right yeah i remember doing that
and uh
you know
and i'm not some new age airy fairy
[ __ ] you know you guys could
just look at me and see i'm [ __ ]
soldier and [ __ ] i'm telling you that's
the way it really is
it was go you go back to the plo roma
that's what the greeks called it the
place where all the gods come from
it was a cosmic singularity all this
[ __ ] singing and [ __ ]
i mean i'm good with that or i'm good
with just not knowing anything both of
those things are fine so
well i was under the impression that if
you enter the plural which is like the
damn cosmic singularity you vanish in
the cosmos the sea of soul
that's cool you in other words it's in
in star wars
in star wars terminology is that you
become one with the force you lose your
individuality
but you love that
you're just going back to where you came
from
you can't get all wrapped up inside the
individual well like i said i mean that
sounds cool and like just falling asleep
and not being aware of anything ever
just like being dead that's cool too
because you wouldn't know any different
right so
either way right it's fine yeah that's
fine because i don't like believe in
hell or another that kind of crap there
were hellish
regions i saw them but they were kind of
voluntary
you go in there because that's what you
wanted to go to do
you want to talk about
i saw they were like low energy regions
in another dimension they are kind of
hellish but they're as hellish as you
want them to be
but when you get sick of that you'll
just come out of it
yeah so yeah it's not reasonable it's
not something you're forced into right
it's like watching the movie
let go let's go hang out in the hallway
for a while
i think part of what it was is is that
if you have a lot of guilt
over something about you you go there to
kind of experience the experience what
you've done to others so you can burn
off those impurities to kind of like
atone for it in a way and then when
you're done you come out of there and
you go okay now i understand
you know it's it's a it's a situation
like that
you know i understand what i did
but it's not a punishment it's more like
uh it's trying to it's like an
intervention
trying to get you to realize or trying
to get a little to try to return balance
to come to terms in terms of what you
did sure that that's and like for you to
be okay with it yeah exactly that's
right yeah to external to internalize
the things that you did
of what it cost other people and what
it's like yes you're like you learned
from it you right exactly and and this
isn't some this is something i saw from
a distance in another dimension
okay i didn't go there i just saw him
and went oh okay yeah i know what that
is
you know
but maybe that's the way people imagine
in a near-death experience i don't think
so i think that's what it was but like
you said that because it seemed like
super this is cool it seemed like super
reality to me seemed like more real than
real
a lot of people have others have said
that but i mean it seems like if there's
anything after death then that seems
like a pretty chill yeah after yeah no
it wasn't uh it wasn't real um uh
[ __ ] uh strict
you know what i'm talking about it made
total sense
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah and then
you're seeing things that are like super
beings you know i mean we're god like
super big he's going how you been how's
it oh yeah i see youtube okay look you
knew them already it's not like you
you're meeting them for the first time
kind of like uh kind of like your
counselor
you know what i mean
yeah all of them and demons type things
were
more kind of just like insectoid
figments of [ __ ] your imagination
of they're very simple type i don't
arrest them hold on
danny rowling says what's friday's movie
review going to be johnny
we did
it's a movie from 1976
called jack the ripper
jess franco directed it klaus kinski is
in it
it has absolutely nothing to do with
jack the ripper other than it being like
a serial killer that kills
prostitutes in
what is ostensibly
late 19th century london but is actually
modern day zurich but okay
um
yeah neither one of us loved it gonna
say but yeah you'll see that was the
movie that we did that was the one that
won
i'd wanna been i had been wanting to do
a jess franco movie for a while
and i just picked this one because i was
like ooh klauskinski is in it and it was
free on to be and i just came across it
randomly so i was like hey why not
and uh tom's like yeah i didn't love
that i was like yeah i didn't love that
either
it had a lot of things that we liked in
it but overall like not great but some
people love it so your milo is blueberry
so okay so where was i all right so
okay
interestingly okay so i think this is
where like you know at the end of the
entity if you've seen it
where they have this whole thing we're
gonna like build a replica of her
apartment or her house or whatever which
they didn't do by the way they're like
yeah we wish we had that much funding
he's like yeah no we never did that but
where they froze the ghost and stuff
i think the idea from that for that came
from this particular thing
so remember how i said earlier that like
the flashing light orbs were like
responding to their questions
one of the questions that they asked and
i'm not sure what the context of this is
i don't really know like how they
got to the point where they were asking
them this question
but they said one of the most intense
responses that they got
was when they asked it
if it was really afraid
of extreme cold like absolute zero type
of cold
and it got like they got like they asked
that question i don't know what led up
to it like i said i don't really know
like what the context of that was but
they asked it a question like that
and apparently they got like a really
really like
you know uh exaggerated reaction so i
think that the fact that that was in the
report that was maybe what
you know influenced the the movie to be
like oh the ghost is scared of being
frozen like absolutely zero so that must
mean we're going to freeze it guys so i
think that's where that what adriana
asked me a question what about sensory
deprivation tanks like an altered state
yes that would work
but that would still be transcendental
meditation okay but that would help you
because there'd be no outside
uh a stimuli
what i would recommend is you know the
in india came up with some good
methods of [ __ ] getting yourself into
the right
mind state to do it would be going up
through chakras with your feet you start
relaxing your feet and you go up to your
knees and your pelvic region and your
chest and your hands and your arms where
you feel where you're relaxing yourself
from there go look at go look at some of
the kind of the indian
um
styles
and uh
that would probably that would probably
put you on the path
to having obe or at least lucid dreaming
because i had some weird [ __ ] that was
or dreaming while awake
um
dream invasion type things where you end
up in somebody else's dream and then
they say dude i saw you in a dream and
it turns out it was like saying
that that can go through uh use you
could probably you could go with those
styles but you don't really need any of
those styles it's all about putting
yourself in the proper mindset faith has
a lot to do with this
and a lot of that transcendental
meditation
actually is just kind of another form of
prayer
just the christian versions like for the
catholic church are so filled with words
and this and that that it's it's not
feelings you know i mean it's not about
distancing the self
i would go for the indian stuff
all right
that might help you
go ahead
but yeah so i think that was where the
final scene of the entity came from
where they were like freezing the ghost
because they did ask it a question if it
was afraid of extreme cold and
that was like the most like sort of like
stringent reaction that they got
so
i like i said i don't know what the
context was for them asking that
question but that was one of the
questions that they asked and it
responded
now i thought this was very interesting
so they said one of the most interesting
things that happened on this particular
night which i believe is the fifth one
they're like we had brought a geiger
counter which i don't believe they had
brought on any uh previous occasion
now uh we were kind of like we wanted to
see what would happen so they said the
geiger counter was behaving very weirdly
in that when the lights were at their
peak intensity meaning when they were
like flashing the most in like you know
when the phenomena would have was at its
height it's like you would think that
the geiger counter would be like going
crazy or anything like that but
it was exactly the opposite
they said
when there was nothing of
you know of consequence going on
um you know the geiger counter would
just
measure like regular background
radiation like you would get anywhere
when the lights were going crazy the
geiger counter showed
zero
radiation
at all which they thought was very weird
because they're like you would think it
would be the opposite like it would be
like way off the charts but it wasn't
they said it was like nothing and
obviously like if you don't know there's
always some kind of like background
radiation either from space or from like
various other things
um so when you have a geiger counter
there's always like a bass line but
they're like when the lights were going
crazy it would go like down to nothing
which they thought was very very strange
um and again like completely
counter-intuitive to like what they
thought would happen
so they thought that that was very weird
so they took some pictures on this
particular night but again even though
they saw like a bunch of these like
crazy [ __ ] uh light things they
didn't get a huge amount of photos
however
this was the night that they got a
couple of the most significant photos
that if you search for doris bither or
energy entity case or something like
that these are uh two of the photos that
come up the most often now one of the
photos is they're both black and white
and one of them is doris like kind of
laying on the bed like sort of going
like that and there's like this big
really bright like arc of light over her
and then there's another uh picture with
i don't think there's any picture people
in it but there's kind of like it's of
the same room and there's these two like
really bright like arcs of light like
like perpendicular to one another
and he's like the interesting thing
about this is like we didn't see it
as
an arc we saw them as like balls of
light
so we're thinking that
even though we had high speed film he
says um he's like i'm kind of thinking
this is like when you have an
astronomical camera and you're kidding
you know it's kind of like a star and
it's like it's like a
stretch you know it's like stretched out
where it's like a ball but it's moving
and you couldn't like capture it in real
time so it's like making it look like an
arc because he's like we didn't see it
as an arc we saw it as a as a ball of
light
and the picture interestingly especially
the real famous one of the arc of light
over doris when she's sitting on the bed
is notable because
the arc of light he's like if you look
like the wall behind her
there's uh it it's you know it's this
wall and that wall so it's like a 90
degree angle
he's like had the light been projected
from another source the light obviously
would have bent
with the angle of the wall as light does
this light does not do that um it looks
like it's floating out in space he's
like which was indeed how we perceived
it like we perceived it as a
three-dimensional
balls of light moving around in the air
it wasn't like a light that was
projected from somewhere y'all can
google the images they're on google
right now i mean yeah they're everywhere
and actually i had it but i forgot to
like put it in obs because they are
weird they're weird
and they've showed it to like you know
photographic experts and everything like
that and they're just kind of like we're
not really entirely sure they're like
obviously this light is not projected
because it's not acting like projected
light this looks like a
three-dimensional
yeah it's not responding to like the
background of the wall in other words
it's just it looks like it's hanging in
mid-air and he said that goes along he's
like we didn't see a streak we saw
balls of light moving
but if he photographed like a ball of
light like a sparkler or something like
that it was moving and like you see it
like a like a streak he's like that's
what this photo looks like to them and
it looks like it was three-dimensional
like it was floating in air and he's
like indeed that's how we perceived it
in real time
so
yeah i mean it doesn't prove anything
but it's pretty weird
it is a pretty weird looking uh picture
and again like the the photo that's
slightly less impressive but is still
like pretty cool of like the two
perpendicular lights
um
these are kind of there's no people in
them but they have had like uh
photographic experts look at that
and they're just kind of like we don't
really know how that particular uh photo
could have been faked or produced like
that because it's
there there's just no way that could
have happened
um
so yeah this was the uh fifth night
now they thought at this point
that um
they were just gonna okay well that's
the end of this uh night of the
investigation we're just gonna go home
and uh we'll be back later
but they said the le the next day after
that like after all of this stuff
doris calls them up in a panic and she
says all the poster boards that they
taped up on the wall because remember
they say they taped it up in a grid
system with like the white duct tape or
whatever
she's like all of them were torn off the
walls um all hell broke loose
that after the afternoon after you guys
left
and um all the poster boards were like
torn off the wall
now at this point they're like well
maybe she tore it off herself like for
attention or whatever
but you know whatever
she also said um i was in the bathroom
which is like right next to the bedroom
and she heard all of the uh
all of the stuff being like forcibly
like torn off the walls like and she
said that there was like uh some of the
paint and the plaster was like pulled
off as well like with the tape
and so she said every single board was
like laying all over the floor
now this tape that they used according
to dr taff was tape that was like i said
used to like tape on like air airplane
parts and stuff like that so it was like
heat resistant it was like really strong
[ __ ] like that it shouldn't have just
been able to fall off but whatever
so
because of this phone call they said
okay well we're gonna go back out there
so they went back that same night so
that's like this is the next night like
after they took those pictures and stuff
like that
and they come in and they see like the
she hadn't moved anything so they had
like all these poster boards like laying
all over the floor and there's tape all
over the floor
and he says like yeah big hunks of like
paint and plaster have been torn off
along with all this tape
which
crazy
now some of them were kind of like well
you know maybe it's humid or maybe it's
hot in here like you know what i mean
like maybe the sticky stuff on the tape
was like you know maybe it wasn't as
adhesive anymore or something
but like he said it was supposed to be
like high temperature tape that wasn't
uh you know
that that wasn't really uh you know
supposed to
[Music]
be
come off like with heat or anything like
that but
you know
he's like well i'm leaving that
possibility open
so
they kind of like examined the boards
and the tape
uh he said the tape was still sticky and
should have been able to support the
boards on the walls
they said another thing they noticed
that particular night coming back was
that again it was like super super cold
in the house which
seems to like argue against the whole
humidity making the tape come off kind
of argument
uh they said it also smelled really bad
in there just like it had before just
like a dead body um and it was like
worse than before
and uh doris also said yeah a bunch of
crazy shit's been happening on like
similar to what had been going on before
so they stayed there for a few hours and
then left like at a little after
midnight
now the sixth time that they came back
to the house this was five days after
that
and they said this was pretty much
very similar to the fifth time they had
been at the house uh they said they saw
like the lights kind of like taking
shape forming
partially they said and a lot of them
saw this and they've done like
recreations of it
you know how they said they'd seen balls
of light right well they said on this
particular night they saw
they're like it didn't come out of the
fog but it was like formed out of these
balls of light they said we all saw what
was very clearly
the top half
of a person i remembered it like an
apparition yeah they said you could very
clearly see
the head and the shoulders and the chest
he's like you couldn't see anything
under that
but it was just he's like you could see
all the muscles in the arms you could
see like the facial features you could
see all of that kind of stuff he's like
it wasn't
he's like i know like sometimes they
they have it like coming out of the fog
or coming out of the light he's like it
wasn't like that he's like it was almost
like built out of the light yeah like it
was this lime green he always said like
the lights were like this lime green
color
that's what color is it it's a lime
green humanoid figure made like out of
half of it plasma it's wasted
part of it and yeah a couple times you
said it looked like plasma it looked
very classy i know what he's talking
about yeah it's kind of like the clear
kind of [ __ ] plasma i saw in the beer
and poltergeist if i could experience if
i remember the clear ball that's what
he's doing
you look at it you're not quite sure
it's there you look up inside of your
eyes you can kind of say no that is
there it's probably what he's talking
about
it's kind of like the stuff that you see
when you rub your eyes the weird color
that's
i think that's what he's talking about
maybe i mean it does seem like a lot of
the people there he said there were like
20 people there and they all saw so well
he said and i'm just going by what he
said in his interview because i saw an
interview with him earlier today
and
he said when we all saw that he's like
after that happened i made everybody in
the room like write down what they had
seen so we could like corroborate like
did we all see the same thing now
probably most likely what he's talking
about
for the listener
these are manifestations of that woman's
subconscious that's what he thought to
you yeah so he thought okay yeah i
believe he's right
what we're talking about is kind of like
a character in one of her dreams but
she's so [ __ ] psychic
and so
keyed up
with this uh [ __ ] weird frustration
that she's made this thing
kind of real so real people can see it
and it's moving objects
yeah
yeah so that's what it is apparently
they all saw this half apparition and in
fact it upset he says that two of the
people that were there like two of the
guys like he's like big guys that were
like had cameras and everything like
that like passed out
because they like their brains couldn't
handle it like what they were seeing
like they and they had to leave and they
never showed up again
so they said this particular night after
seeing that like half apparition
that the lights were so intense he said
they were basically like illuminating
the whole room because i you know as i
mentioned earlier they didn't have like
the overhead lights on or nothing like
that sometimes they had like a candle or
two but that's about it but they usually
kept the lights real low because they
wanted to be able to see the light
anomalies like more clearly he's like
the [ __ ] was so bright that you could
like very clearly see everyone's faces
you could see everything in there
because the lights
were so bright
so they were kind of like
they again they started like trying to
take pictures of it
um and he says it's like we had a couple
cameras and we set them at uh five
minute time exposures so that means they
were you know the the shutter was open
for like a really long time so they're
trying to get like these whole like uh
burst of light activity
now they didn't really get they also had
a couple i think they had a couple of
video cameras i don't know if it was
this time but like a little bit later on
but they were kind of like these cameras
were just
kept like taking pictures the whole time
um
but the weird thing about it again
was that even though everybody in the
room was allegedly seeing all of this
crazy light activity
he says all of the negatives that night
that they took
came out what he called quote unquote
perfectly clear
as if no light whatsoever
was present to expose the film
so the negative like yeah it would be
clear because like when you expose it it
would be black
so he's like even though that shouldn't
have happened
because there was a lot of light in the
room so if you took a picture
it should have taken a picture of the
light but he's like it didn't all the
negatives came out
completely clear so the photos would
have been completely black like there
was absolutely no light he's like even
though everybody saw light
in the room so much so that we could
clearly see everyone's faces
uh so he thought that was very very
weird so he's like well what kind of
light is this
because it's obviously illuminating
things
but it's not turning up on film
so he thought that was very weird like i
said this could all be [ __ ] i don't
really know but this is what he was
saying
um so he speculated maybe maybe this is
long wave ultraviolet radiation just
above visible light that's what he says
um maybe that this was the light
generated by the phenomenon
um
you know it could be [ __ ] but taft's
been around for a long time he has and
he's been centered around this case in
this case only i mean he's been on a
bunch of other cases yeah but he mostly
talks about this one
it's not the kind of situation where you
have like with the warrens where [ __ ]
every [ __ ] tuesday they got a new
possession cases well in every case
that's like high up in the media they're
just kind of like oh hey do you need our
assistance it's demons but i would say i
would say
more credible than that
yeah um
what he's seeing is different than what
i saw but i saw some wild [ __ ] too
me and my family
um not quite this well ours wasn't that
visual more about objects moving
but for me this is plausible
we saw stuff also it's just that ours
wasn't just well you saw something that
was more like it wasn't light it was
more like a weird fog yeah fog a weird
[ __ ] fog type thing that you couldn't
quite focus on
or the feeling of being watched up in
corners of [ __ ] up towards the
ceiling you look and there's some kind
of weird
kind of clear distortion
kind of like
the only thing i
kind of like the [ __ ] thing from
predator from predator one you know i
mean you have the [ __ ] weird clear
distortion like that but not as not as
not as distinct not as distinct and you
weren't quite
convinced that you were actually seeing
it you're like is that really there or
is that my imagination but everybody's
going yeah is that there is that our
imagination you know it's just
you know it's just like you called it a
blue haze that's what you call well the
blue haze yeah but but the blue haze and
the things that would
the round clear balls were different it
was two different effects i call it a
round clear ball but you weren't really
sure that it was there
you just felt that it was watching you
and everybody else was like is that
there like yeah i think that is there it
looks like there's something there when
you looked right at it you didn't see
anything but out of the corner of your
eye you could kind of see like a little
round clear ball
up in the
up near the ceiling in the corners
just like all
and so and then the same place me and
redder be like well it's not there now
like oh yeah it's gone
you know what i mean it's like one of
their temperament so y'all were like
seeing the same yeah really you all knew
that there was something i don't want to
see seeing it was like we we were
detecting it yeah couldn't see anything
out of the corner of your eye you could
kind of detect that there was a
disturbance there and then like it was
watching you when you looked right at it
there was nothing there if you looked
off to the side it felt like there was a
little bit of a
little bit of a [ __ ] distortion there
but there's just no way to describe it
you had to be there
you know a lot of it was feeling
so
when it came to like optical effects the
the the blue haze and that weird clear
thing
i'm gonna plug the book i have mountain
poultry guys you guys can buy it i'll
tell the whole story there jenny [ __ ]
does a good job of telling it
most of it's there some of the stuff we
couldn't mention exactly where it was
but on the show i'll tell you where it
is
um
and we included some stuff from wesley
that that was wesley's idea of [ __ ]
what it was but i'm not sure how
accurate it was
well i just went by the like letter what
he said what he said right he knew
something was up but he
quite couldn't but lois and red were
like oh yeah that was [ __ ] bizarre
just
it was
it's like it was unreal man it was just
another form of [ __ ] reality some
kind of weird poltergeist activity to
distort in reality it's weird
objects being thrown objects being
teleported
lights moving or you see the switches
moving on lights lights flashing off and
on rocking chairs being rocked [ __ ]
[ __ ] was stacking towels everywhere and
[ __ ] wrapping them around the back of
[ __ ] door handles and
weird
weird
so would respond to what you were
talking about
you could hear it jumping down on up
jumping up and down on beds
behind doors that were closed and you
open the door and there's nothing going
on in there and [ __ ] rearranged threw a
pin at me did all kinds of weird stuff
it was [ __ ] scary and then it
happened at lois's house a couple days
later
and it happens off and on
over the years if i think about it too
much it doesn't matter where i am
well that kind of goes along with yeah
yours and
barry taft's
theory yeah
that this is caused by a person yeah and
not like a haunting no
no because this is something that
follows because and the same thing
happened in this case um it did seem to
follow her like after she moved
i mean allegedly
so the seventh visit that they did to
doris's house um when they got there
dora said you should have been here last
night all hell broke loose again
she said what happened
was there was these two
candelabras and they flew off the
kitchen sink and flew across the room
which was about 10 to 12 feet
and hit her in the arm
um doris's son corroborated this and
said yeah that was what happened
um and they barely kind of like they
just flew by him and almost hit him but
then like they hit the mom
and they also said that the same day
there was this big wooden board which
had been nailed to the wall under one of
the bedroom windows
uh tore off
and uh went about 15 feet across the
room uh almost missing the sun's head
like it just kind of flew by his head
so uh barry taft didn't see any of this
but he was just uh they said it happened
the night before
so
barry says um they saw the bruise on
doris's forearm which she said came from
the candelabras
so uh again they went into the bedroom
and said that all of the all the poster
board that they had taped up they had
re-taped up like after they've been had
been torn off once again
so again a bunch of paint and plaster
had come off now they're like well
obviously like doris could have done
this but
it seems strange that she would like
they said well one she was like real a
really small woman it's like it would
seem like to take a lot of force to like
pull all the plaster off the wall
so it's like they're not discounting the
possibility that she did it but the you
know they're just saying
uh you know they're leaving [ __ ] open
you know what i'm saying
now on this particular evening the
seventh uh they brought
i don't want to say with their boss but
like the head of the parapsychology
department when he was dr thelma moss
uh at ucla
and she came along with him this night
and almost as if
if it was you know whatever the force
was knew that there was someone like in
higher authority there
it didn't do as much that night
i will know too that frank defalida the
guy that wrote the book uh was there
also um as well as a bunch of other
people
but the fact that
she was there
dr thelma moss because she had been
asking about it and she wanted to like
come along to the investigation and they
were telling her like all this crazy
[ __ ] that had happened and so they were
kind of hoping that all of this stuff
would happen while she was there
but it didn't
so it's like really kind of it's like a
couple minor things happen but like
nothing uh approximating like what they
had seen before
so they did actually tape up all the
poster boards again and they did another
seance they said we saw a couple like
little
kind of like [ __ ] like little lights
here and there
but it wasn't anything like what they
had seen
before uh they tried to do some more
photographs nothing came out
nothing came out on film
and they played like the black sabbath
records and [ __ ] like that because they
thought and then it didn't really like
do anything because they were trying to
like hype it up for because the boss was
there so it started and she wanted to
see it she wanted to see it
uh so they didn't really see any of the
stuff that had gone on before
so you know what i mean starting to
peter out now one thing that did happen
though like at one point carrie gainer
says
um why don't you show us like what a big
man you are or whatever why don't you
tear these poster boards off again like
while we're here
now apparently five seconds after he
asked that
the poster boards over doris's head
did like
pull off the wall and like hit her so
[ __ ] did happen
it just wasn't as crazy as like what had
happened before
um so yeah he said it looked like
he said it looked like an invisible hand
was like pulling the duct tape off
and then like the boards were coming off
and like it was just like poster board
it wasn't like wood or anything but they
were they were kind of like pulling off
and like flying across the room and they
did kind of like hit her
so she saw something like a hand
an invisible hand i mean they didn't say
like but they just said it looked like
something was pulling it okay you know
it just looked like something was
pulling the tape off you know what i
mean i've never seen that okay
so in that case nothing ever moved if
you were looking directly at it
it's always something out of the corner
i mean i don't know if they were looking
dire i mean i would think that they
probably were because he asked it hey
tear these boards off the walls because
he had because the entity apparently had
torn the boards off the walls twice
before although they hadn't seen it
firsthand but this time so they asked it
they're like oh well if you're so big
why don't you do it like while we're
looking at you jenny's seen my
poltergeist and [ __ ] the other gin
that hottie with the [ __ ] black hair
that i showed you guys earlier her and
her husband were sitting right on the
couch when
yeah they were here like when yeah it
wasn't this house was the other house
when that [ __ ] damn remote
flew off the [ __ ]
table and landed on the ground
and then i stood up what the [ __ ] was
that and i looked down there were some
[ __ ] coins at my feet a stack of them
that was some weird [ __ ] stack of coins
how'd the [ __ ] coins get there they
were from my [ __ ] bad side
that was so weird [ __ ]
it was yeah
but one thing that he did note about
this particular visit he's like well
unlike most of our previous visits
doris was a lot less
emotionally volatile it's like she was a
lot more chilled out
um
she wasn't drunk
like i said
generally the drunker she got like the
crazier the the phenomena would get yeah
but because she was like pretty chill
and like pretty sober this time around
they are thinking that maybe that's why
it wasn't as crazy
um they're like we don't know if that's
why but he's like i'm just speculating
that maybe that's why it wasn't like uh
is crazy enough
so
he was kind of like bummed out because
like even though a couple like minor
things did happen he was kind of hoping
that like more [ __ ] would happen because
you know like i said the [ __ ] head of
the parapsychology department was there
but
you know everything that happened
they're like the [ __ ] coming off the
walls they're like ah that could have
just been humidity or that could have
been like but you know there was still
like
a plausible explanation he's like and i
was trying to explain to her no we saw
these crazy like light balls and stuff
like that but we didn't see anything
like that like while she was there which
was kind of a bummer
so they came to the house one more time
their eighth uh and final visit to the
house and this was again this happened
over like two and a half months they had
been there like eight times
and this actually happened on halloween
night of 1974. uh he said it was also a
full moon so there you go
now they brought all kind of like more
equipment for this last night you know
uh what he calls an image intensifier
which had like a low light video
recording thing
um and he's like well maybe this will
like record uh stuff that the cameras
won't pick up
now doris again was sober on this
particular night and again this night
was like pretty much a total uh wash
nothing nothing much happened they said
really
they said it was even like less
impressive than the previous time where
they'd at least have some like [ __ ]
coming off the walls and everything uh
they said pretty much all that happened
was like oh the room got cold for a
second and it was like a bad smell for
like a couple seconds
but
that was about it they said they didn't
see any weird lights they didn't see
anything like that
um but again they noted that doris was a
lot more chilled out she wasn't hostile
she wasn't swearing she wasn't drunk she
wasn't anything like that
um she wasn't afraid of the stuff going
on so they think maybe there was a
correlation uh there between why she she
wasn't like upset so that's why it
wasn't like [ __ ] uh you know acting
out
so
i don't really know so after that they
said they pretty much lost track of
doris uh for a little while
now she moved uh away from culver city
and she kind of didn't phone them
afterward
and they had to find her like themselves
and
after that um
it was about three months after that
they said february of 1975
they found her again like to her new
place where they'd moved to
and they said that the phenomena had
continued in her new house but
substantially diminished
um as is what usually happens in these
kind of situations
so i mean the thing about it and the
thing about it too is that allegedly
uh the new place that she moved to
um
from everything that i've heard
at least
one or two of her neighbors like the
houses on either side of her
before they knew who she was
reported
some activity in their own houses her
neighbors
i don't know if that's true or not but
that's kind of like the story and he
reports it as well he's like when we uh
got back in contact with her and talked
to her neighbors
they said that weird [ __ ] had started
happening in their houses
before they had met her like after she
moved in but before they knew anything
about her and knew who she was
so
it's possible i don't know but i'm just
saying that that's kind of one of the
things that they always said that this
is so again he's
he's like yeah it was weird that the
lights like responded to our questions
like almost like it was a like an entity
that was intelligent
but he's 99 sure that this was again
rspk these like it was
um
she had
a very troubled past which had to do
with like drug abuse alcoholism like uh
abuse by maybe her family
and uh for sure her some of her
boyfriends had like abused her
and so she was like a troubled woman
and she had a very strange uh and
strained relationship with her three
sons
uh which was very evident to somebody
that had just uh met them like like i
said dr barry taft thought that was very
like um
very evident like from the first time
that he met her
so um
he speculated that probably her mental
state was projecting this
entity or entities that this was
something she was doing i agree um he
doesn't think that she was i don't think
that he thinks she was particularly
aware of it like that she was doing it
on purpose becoming aware of it foils it
yeah that's what i'm saying like i i
think she thought that it was an outside
force yeah and well you know according
to what you said and i think this is
probably true that
thinking that it's an outside force is
like inherent in
making it happen yeah if you know if you
know that it's you then it's not going
to do it anymore because well it doesn't
serve the purpose you need right because
the purpose of the thing is to bind the
family together by
making a false outside threat
all right and that'll bind everybody
together to keep family from breaking
apart so she doesn't want to she doesn't
want to lose her sons
so at a subconscious level she's doing
this psychic phenomenon to make a
outside threat to bond herself with her
sons whether it worked or not uh
probably not right but that's what she's
trying to do i would imagine not
everybody lost track of her after about
1990. okay dr taff said he didn't hear
uh about her he didn't hear from her
anymore after 1983 or thereabouts like
after the entity came out yeah um she
did still communicate with frank
defolita the guy that wrote the novel
um up until 1990 or 1991 but um after
that like neither of them as far as i
know like heard from her anymore she did
i don't know
um
back then
so this was 1974.
she was he said he's she was about in
her mid-30s in 1974 yeah so she may have
been dead she may be dead i don't really
know yeah um her kids are probably still
alive but the thing about it is that
maybe they don't really want the
publicity maybe
who knows and it seemed like she didn't
really
she didn't really seem to be doing this
for the publicity because as soon as it
like it got popular she was like nope
i'm out and she just like kind of
disappeared like i said after the movie
came out
nobody really knew where where she took
off to there was a thing later where
um
you know and and barry taff talked about
this too like he didn't uh he only found
about out about this later but she said
that the you know the the entity that
was supposedly raping her had gotten her
pregnant
okay now
apparently she did kind of go but it's a
hysterical pregnancy which does happen
sometimes
um
they said that she did have that the
hysterical pregnancy she
thought she was pregnant she started
like
showing like symptoms of pregnancy but
there was no fetus in there right
basically
oh that's some bizarre [ __ ] it was
because women are weird man you women
i'm sorry how the hell can you have a
[ __ ]
so you could fake your own pregnancies
if you i even know i've never done that
but that's weird you really have to
believe it very strongly i would imagine
i don't i don't think i have the
capacity to like believe some [ __ ] like
that that's wrong weird [ __ ]
i'm sorry yeah women are ali women are
aliens not gonna understand
psychosomatics you know
it's funny to me though how
it's funny to me how dudes are like so
like weirded out by like i guess because
y'all don't have babies
or periods or anything like that so it's
like a really alien like concept yeah
you're like what you like it's really
not that weird to me like i've never so
pregnant that you get pregnant but
there's no babies i've never had a baby
damn but
um
it's not like that weird of a concept
some weird [ __ ] to a man i guess i was
thinking about it well i was thinking
about it the other day because i was
reading like you know if you read it as
a ghost baby it's a ghost baby
[Laughter]
if you like listen to my book reviews i
just read um scott smith's a simple plan
uh which the sam raimi movie was based
on it's an excellent book by the way it
came out in the early 90s um if you want
if you're into like thrillers like
really dark [ __ ] thrillers it's
excellent and the funny thing about it
is that
the dude that's the protagonist like his
wife is pregnant
and there's a couple scenes in there
where he just keeps like touching her
belly and like the the baby's like
kicking and stuff and he's like
completely like weirded and grossed out
by it because like oh my god like
there's a person in there that's like
[ __ ] weirding me out which like i
said if you think about it from that
point of view yeah it sounds like pretty
weird i guess to me it's not weird
because
you know that's just like what happens
it's natural yeah um
but yeah i can see from a dude's point
of view i wasn't in bubbly oh my god
there's another person in there grody
but that's where you came from too
that's where people come from yeah you
you came out of someone's body i i hate
to like be the person to break my
[ __ ] are detached from reality
nowadays it's biology [ __ ]
well that's what i'm saying it's not
really that well i i think that's kind
of the it's an extension of like why i'm
so amused by why dudes are so grossed
out by menstruation because i'm just
kind of like okay okay i got all kinds
of chicken this is the end of the show
um i think so yeah i just said yeah the
they lost track of her so i as far as i
could tell i tried to like find out what
happened to her right and apparently
nobody's really here for like like i
said frank defilitter heard from her in
the like 1990 or 1999
um but as far as i know
nobody's heard from her since then i
wasn't going to like look her up on
facebook jesus christ she probably just
wants she's probably she probably wants
to be left alone she's probably she's an
old woman she's probably an old woman on
my facebook she's in her 70s and
obviously she didn't want to make any
money off of this [ __ ] or anything like
that because as soon as the movie came
out she was like she disappeared like
and nobody really knew anything that
happened to her
but
so
i don't know was she a crazy person
i don't know i i kind of feel like maybe
yeah she had some issues but i think
those issues were maybe causing some
like [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] to happen right
yeah
i don't know what to think
a lot of people like saw weird ass [ __ ]
in their [ __ ] staff said she was
disturbed
but he also said the phenomena was real
so a lot of people saw it well that's
the thing though it's like maybe you
have to be kind of disturbed for this
[ __ ] to happen yeah you got to be
frustrated and [ __ ] pissed off yeah
she had a lot of problems but like i
said maybe you have to have a lot of
problems from my experience i mean
because yeah the the phenomena that's
described in this
um
that that many people witnessed yeah
it's crazy
i mean they saw some crazy [ __ ]
it wasn't just like that's um cheese
it's catnip okay okay it's catnip i
thought that was spray cheese look at
cheese whiz why would i have cheese
whisk
it's catnip spray
i spray it on her i look like i have
another one that's already open i bought
it in a two pack
when she gets sick of her toys i spray
cat nip on the toys so she plays with
them again
you know yeah duh adriana says wikipedia
says doris spitter died in night oh okay
yeah that makes sense okay okay okay all
right i kind of figured she must be dead
but you know but i mean i kind of feel
like she fell out of the public
consciousness it wasn't like she was
trying to cash in on the [ __ ] right she
really seemed like she didn't even want
to hear 1999 she wasn't that old when
she died then
yeah if she was in her mid-30s in 1974
so she can't math
maybe
50s when she died
okay well um look i got chicken down
there waiting before you want some
chicken sure okay go ahead and shut it
down all right four hours and still
coherent i know i'm i'm proud of us four
hours wait did kind of ozil just show up
just now oh man go ahead check out on
yeah all right i'm going to start i was
like proud of us that we were going like
four hours but yeah i mean this is a
crazy ass case like i said i'm not a
super like believer in paranormal kind
of [ __ ]
too and i mean you know up to a point
but a lot of people saw this it was
weird [ __ ] i'm not saying it's
supernatural i'm not saying it's nothing
like that but it is pretty weird that
they all saw what they that they saw and
i do think it's significant that
doris
um yeah she had some issues but i don't
think she was just trying to like do it
for
the money obviously because i don't
really know how much money she got out
of this [ __ ] and she just like pretty
much disappeared afterward
and she didn't really try to like stay
in the limelight so
i don't know i don't know what her
motivation was
but this is a pretty [ __ ] weird case
by the
you know by any [ __ ] stretch of the
imagination
so yeah uh if you haven't seen the
entity from 1982
then definitely check that out the end
now keep in mind it's exaggerated
obviously the ending of it where they
freeze the ghost that absolutely did not
happen
um and it's a little bit
out there that's kind of where the movie
loses me
but other than that it's like a really
good movie it's just you know
it's not it goes kind of off the rails
like in the last in the last act but uh
up to then it's like it's very very good
so
you know there's that all right so we're
gonna wrap it up well i'm gonna wrap it
up because he already took off because
he's like i'm hungry i'm going but yeah
so we will see you guys again on friday
night for our side tracks show so
hopefully you guys drop by and see us
then and hopefully you enjoyed this
paranormal extravaganza that we did this
evening this was actually really fun we
should do this again at some point we
didn't do another haunting episode i
feel like
one of these days we'll do it
but yeah so thank you everybody for
dropping by thank you everybody for
super chats and we will see you guys on
friday evening
bye